Exzellent, auf geht's!
Voll die MonkaS Musik, oder?
Die Sticke MonkaS Soundtrack.
Oh, wer weiß auf welchem Game das ist.
Okay, in einem Moment zieht's oben in der Leiste.
Kack Wade, weiß jeder.
Beste Quest, Alter.
Beste Quest ever.
In dem Game.
Also fand ich zumindest.
Also eine der besten.
Die Message gerade über Twitter.
Leute, Twitter hat die letzten Tage ganz viel Disfollowed.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich was Falsches geschrieben hab.
Irgendwie.
Aber es ist immer plus, drei, vier Tage minus.
Cancel Culture.
Genau, jetzt auch auf Twitter.
Auf Twitter fängt's immer an.
Warum haben wir eigentlich jede Musik, die creepy wirken soll.
Singende Kinder.
Wirkt das creepiger?
Nee, nee, das könnte tatsächlich eine Asiatin sein.
Im Kontext von dem Game sind's Kinder.
Und sie singen über den Teufel, so viel weiß ich noch.
Oder zumindest so was in der Richtung.
MonkaS, ja, aber richtig MonkaS.
MonkaSmoke.
Ja, also genug creepy Kindergesänge.
Ist vielleicht nicht der beste Einstück für Progar Street.
Wobei wir programmieren heute gar nichts.
Ah, extra, kommen wir mal ein bisschen.
Alter, ich hab mich grad voll.
Mein Güte, Keg-Wade.
So, also, was wollen wir uns heute angucken?
Ist folgendes.
Und zwar wollte ich mal ein paar Fonts ausprobieren.
Die was taugen, hoffe ich.
Ihr wisst ja, ich verwende schon seit...
Alter, das ist mir alles zu episch für heute.
Das ist mir zu...
Oh, das Ori-Main-Theme ist so nice, Leute.
Bestes.
Das ist ohne Scheiß...
Das Ori-Menü-Theme ist wirklich Poggers.
Ich weiß, wir sind nicht hier für Game-Musik, aber das ist wirklich nice.
Echt nice.
Terminus auf 9P.
Ich mach mir gleich ne Liste mit Schriften, die man ausprobieren.
Bom Bom, Dankeschön für den...
Zwei Monaten Sub.
Das meine ich übrigens gar nicht.
Warte mal.
Ori-Main.
Ach, das.
Ja, das meine ich.
Aber das gibt's bestimmt noch besser.
Hm.
Main-Menü.
Das meine ich.
Ach, ist das Microsoft Studios?
Wusste ich gar nicht.
Excellent.
Das ist ultra...
Sadge.
Sadge-Musik, ja.
Oh, Leute.
Teams hat wieder einmal Mikro rumgespielt.
Ich seh's sofort.
Keg-Waite.
So.
So, ich mach mal schnell meine VM an.
Also...
Qt-VM.
Nein, die Qt-VM...
Na, komm.
Chat, weil ihr's seid.
Weil ihr's seid.
Ich mach jetzt kurz die Qt-VM an.
Ich weiß, der Chat freut sich immer.
Bin nervos.
Morgen Projekt-Doku abgeben.
Das war auf den letzten Drücker.
Meiner auch.
Meine war auch auf den letzten Drücker.
Hast du das Projekt wirklich gemacht
oder hast du was zusammengefakt?
So, eine Runde für den Chat.
So.
Genug.
Qt-Ladung für heute erledigt.
Hab's gemacht, aber nur teilweise...
Ja, das ist nicht schlimm.
Also, es will ja keiner sehen oder so.
Was hast du denn gemacht, wenn ich fragen darf?
In welche Richtung?
Also, du musst jetzt nicht
den kompletten Titel reinschreiben, ne?
Aber so ungefähr.
MDM übereinbestimmt.
MDM ist das Mobile Device Management.
Es gibt mittlerweile so viel 3 Buchstaben-Abkürzungen,
dass ich da nicht mehr durchblicke.
Was ist das für ein Command heute?
Er ist Mobile Device Management, okay.
Naja, die IHK freut sich ja immer drüber,
wenn da ein kleiner oder auch etwas größerer
kaufmännischer Teil dabei ist.
Also, ich hab ja auch so ein hässliches
Gantia-Gramm drinne.
NR...
Nicht Rationales Datenbank...
Was ist MS?
Also, quasi so eine NoSQL-Datenbank ist das.
Richtig, ja.
Boah, wir haben ja noch Glück gehabt hier.
Ja, die IHK steht halt unglaublich drauf,
wenn man so ein bisschen
kaufmännischen Kram reinwurstet, ja.
Ja, das mögen sie.
Das mögen sie.
Gantia-Gramm ist ganz hässlich.
Also, wer es nicht kennt,
ich hab in meiner Abschlussprojektdokumentation
ein Gantia-Gramm in MS-Project gemacht.
So was hier.
Aber das war kein neues,
das war MS-Project 2003 oder so.
Alter.
Boah.
Boah, meine Güte, wenn ich das sehe.
Ich krieg Anfälle.
Guckt euch diesen Müll an.
Schrecklich, schrecklich, Alter.
Schrecklich.
Guckt euch das...
Boah, kotzen, Alter.
Huge.
Jetzt weiß ich aber,
warum es zwei verschiedene Kotz-Emojis gibt.
Die wurden nur geschaffen
für Microsoft-Project.
SiriusMax, 11 Monate.
Dankeschön.
Das ist ja ein, zwei Hyper-Subscriber.
Aber du kriegst jetzt schon mal
den Hyper-Subscriber.
Weil, excellent Mod.
Das muss man ja auch nicht machen.
Das habe ich reingemacht,
weil ich absolut nicht wusste,
was ich da für kaufmännischen Gramm
reinmachen sollte.
Also ich hatte zwei kaufmännische Sachen
in meinem Abschlussprojekt drinne.
Das war einmal...
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Inekol?
Oder Neck?
Oi.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber Dankeschön für den Sub.
Zwei Monate, drei Monate.
Und jetzt kommt noch AC11994.
Dankeschön für zwei Monate.
Hyper-Massive-Subscription.
IQ++++++ heute schon wieder.
Toff, ich habe nichts übersehen.
Beastmode hat auch 13 Monate schon.
Hyper.
Richtig Hyper-Subscription.
Massive-Prain-Subs wieder heute.
Ich sehe es schon.
Ich habe die Hälfte mitgekriegt.
Flamongo.
Ja, NoSQL am Start hier.
Sieben Monate.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Also ich hatte zwei
kaufmännische Sachen drinne
in meiner Abschlussarbeit.
Die eine kaufmännische Sache
in meiner Abschlussarbeit
war so ein hässliches Gantia-Kram.
Und die zweite Sache
war so eine Produktauswahl,
wo zufälligerweise das Produkt gewonnen hat,
was ich von Anfang an machen wollte.
War halt übelst zusammengefakt.
Es hat übrigens nicht ganz hingehauen.
Ich brauche mal ein bisschen
was fröhlicheres an Musik hier.
Komm, Mario Kart geht immer.
Jawoll.
Ja.
Im Zweifelfall ist...
Okay, machen wir mal was anderes.
Happy, Happy.
Happy Nintendo Music.
Was haben wir da?
Jolly Joker.
Dankeschön.
Acht Monate.
Happy Music.
Jawoll.
Ich brauche irgendwas anderes.
Happy, Happy.
Happy Music Nintendo.
Ja.
Sowas.
Okay, passt.
Hotter.
Eine Entscheidungsmatrix, ja.
Also eine Entscheidungsmatrix hatte ich,
wie gesagt, in meinem Abschlussprojekt drin.
Also das Problem war,
ich habe ein VPN gebaut für mein Abschlussprojekt.
Und zwar mit OpenVPN.
Das ist 13 Jahre her.
Also das habe ich mit OpenVPN gemacht.
Und das Problem war,
ich musste der IHK irgendwie begründen,
warum ich das mit OpenVPN mache.
Und ich habe da ein paar VPN-Sachen zur Auswahl gehabt
in so einer Tabelle.
Und ich wollte halt OpenVPN machen.
Und ich hatte im Prinzip auch schon im Vorfeld geguckt,
wie es mit OpenVPN geht.
Das heißt, ich musste für meine Abschlussprüfung
in irgendeiner Art und Weise zusammenfaken,
dass OpenVPN gewinnt.
So, und ich hatte dann zur Auswahl OpenVPN,
IPSEC,
ähm,
wie heißt das von Microsoft?
PPTP oder sowas?
Gibt es das?
Jaja, da ist das von Microsoft, der Crap.
Und ich hatte noch ein Viertes.
Ich hatte noch ein Viertes.
Was fällt denn euch noch ein?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich hatte vier.
Was gibt es denn sonst noch?
OpenVPN,
PPTP,
IPSEC, na WireGuard gab es 2007 noch nicht.
L2TP, korrekt.
L2TP, L2TP, genau.
L2TP.
So, und
ich musste das irgendwie so zurechtrücken,
dass OpenVPN gewinnt.
Das Problem war, ich hatte in der Entscheidungsmatrix
drinnen so wie welche Geräte
das Out of the Box unterstützen.
Und da hat IPSEC halt mileinweit gewonnen,
weil alle Geräte IPSEC kannten.
Also ich hatte nix, wo OpenVPN wirklich viel besser war als IPSEC.
So, und dann habe ich,
dann habe ich voll zusammen gefakt,
dann habe ich einen Punkt eingeführt,
Open Source.
Was schwachsinnig ist, im Prinzip ist das alles mehr oder weniger Open Source.
Und da hat dann, weil wir Cisco-Switches verwendet haben,
habe ich dann gesagt, okay, aber die Cisco-Implementierung
IPSEC ist nicht Open Source,
und deswegen gewinnt OpenVPN.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt bis heute keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt.
Die verwenden wahrscheinlich eine fixe und fertige
IPSEC-Implementierung,
die genauso Open Source ist wie alles andere auch.
Aber ich musste mir das irgendwie zusammenfaken,
dass OpenVPN gewinnt.
Clocks.ad, 19 Monate lang, schon Hyper-Subscription.
Nee, in dem Fall war das egal,
weil es ging von Rechenzentrum Standort zu Rechenzentrum Standort, ging's drum.
Da ist egal, ob da irgendjemand was blockt oder nicht.
Ja, sieben Spatzgranate, danke schön.
Zwölf Monate Abo-Falle.
Kommst nicht raus, keine Chance, der Cancel-Button ist weg.
Einfach gelöscht.
Abgabe ist morgen.
Ja, macht dir keine Gedanken, das wird schon passen.
Wichtig ist, wie lief es?
Wie lief es?
Das wird schon passen.
Wichtig ist, wie lief deine Abschlussprüfung?
Hast du schon irgendwelche Ergebnisse?
Euch hatte ich schon alle, ne?
Ich werde auf Mega-Pfeifer dann drei ausgedruckte Dokus...
Ja, hey, das ist eine gute Idee, ohne Mist.
Du kannst bestimmt ein bisschen punkten.
Nur GH1.
Also ich fand bei der Abschlussprüfung das Schlimmste war der Visoteil.
Das liegt mir halt überhaupt nicht.
Ich hab's euch ja schon öfters erzählt.
Ich hab ja bevor ich Physi gelernt habe, hab ich BWL-technisch was gemacht.
Und seitdem krieg ich Anfälle bei allem, was mit BWL zu tun hat.
Also meine ersten beruflichen Versuche im BWL-Umfeld
hab ich's fürs Leben zum BWL-Hasser gemacht.
Jaja, ich hab, nein, war ich nicht, war ich nie.
War ich nie.
Ich hab damit angefangen, Bürokaufmann zu machen.
Gibt's hier einen Beruf überhaupt noch?
Ja, Bürokaufinnen ist es heute.
Und ich hab das nicht lang gemacht.
Alter, ich hasse ganzen BWL-Kram.
Und wie gesagt, eines der wenigen Sachen, was ich mir gemerkt hab, ist
die Buchhalternase und dass man linear und degressiv abschreiben kann.
Welche ich fürs Leben nie wieder brauchen.
Aber das hab ich mir gemerkt aus meiner BWL-Ausbildung.
Oder zumindest aus den paar Monaten BWL.
Hast du danach studiert?
Nee, nee, danach hab ich den ganzen Tag MMO gegrindet.
Also, okay Leute, ich muss euch jetzt erzählen, wie das war.
Ich hab den ganzen Tag MMO gegrindet.
Und meine Mutter und mein Vater haben gesagt, du musst jetzt mal langsam irgendwas machen.
Weil Schule war fertig und so.
Und ich hab den ganzen Tag MMO gegrindet.
Und dann bin ich am anderen Tag rauf gestanden und hab weiter MMO gegrindet.
Auf welchem Server hast du gezockt bei Dawg?
Ich hab gezockt auf...
Ich hab auf mehrere gespielt.
Ich hab auf Stonehenge angefangen.
Danach hab ich Lioness gespielt.
Auch ein bisschen.
Dann...
Wie ist der Classic-Server?
Salisbury hab ich gespielt.
Und dann auf dem US-Server.
Erstmal auf Canterbury US-Server.
Und danach noch auf...
Ach frag mich nicht, ich war auf einem Mann auf diesem Cluster.
Aber...
Ich hab da so viele Stunden reingesteckt und das Game ist nicht normal.
Byte Strike?
Jaja, war er auch.
Aber nicht lang.
Der war ja nie im Knast, so wirklich.
Der war in Untersuchungshaft, das ist ja was anderes.
Der war nicht im Knast.
Warum weißt du das überhaupt?
Hab ich das...
Ja, das hab ich erzählt.
Na klar, sonst wüsstet ihr das wahrscheinlich nicht.
Der war in Untersuchungshaft.
Der war nicht im Knast.
Außerdem war das nicht lange.
Zumindest...
Zumindest, ich hab halt...
Ich bin morgens aufgestanden, hab MMO gegrindet.
Und dann bin ich ins Bett gegangen, bin morgens aufgestanden, hab MMO gegrindet.
Und dann hab ich zwischenzeitlich nachts teilweise noch ein bisschen Really Raid MMO gegrindet.
So, easy.
Und ich hab wirklich Hardcore MMO gegrindet die ganze Zeit.
Irgendwann hat dann mein Vater und meine Mutter gesagt...
Also, die...
Unabhängig voneinander, die hatten damals schon gar nicht mehr so viel miteinander zu tun.
Die haben halt unabhängig voneinander gesagt, du musst jetzt mal irgendwas machen.
Und ich hab halt gesagt, nö.
So, nee, warum?
Warum sollte ich was machen?
Ich kann auch einfach den ganzen Tag MMO-Kreisel grinden.
Und für mich war das eine gute Idee.
Ich hatte, sag mal so, genug Geld, dass ich meine monatliche Subscription für das MMO bezahlen konnte.
Und der Rest hat mich nicht interessiert.
Da hab ich dann einfach gesagt, nö, will ich nicht machen.
So.
Und irgendwann musste ich dann mal zum Arbeitsamt...
Da musste ich ja dann diesen scheiß Kurs machen.
Das hab ich euch ja erzählt.
Das hab ich euch ja erzählt hier in dem Video, diesen komischen Kurs da beim Arbeitsamt.
So, und danach hab ich dann angefangen.
Hab gesagt, komm, machst du einfach irgendwas.
Und das einfachste war, weil es eben halt auch massig Stellen gab.
Und im Prinzip ich das auf halber Arschbacke bekommen hab, obwohl ich sie gar nicht wollte.
Hab ich mir was für Bürokaufmänner gesucht.
Und ich wollte das ja nie machen.
Und es war das beschissenste, was ich je gemacht hab.
Also nichts gegen Bürokaufmänner, aber es ist halt BWL-Zeug.
Es ist halt überhaupt nicht meins.
Ich hab das einfach nur gemacht, weil ich halt irgendwas machen sollte.
Hätte ich mal lieber was mit Holz gemacht, ja.
Und wie gesagt, das einzige, was ich mir gemerkt habe, war tatsächlich die Buchhalternase.
Und dass man linear und degressiv abschreiben kann.
Ah ja.
Und so.
Und dann irgendwann hab ich gesagt, also nach nicht allzu langer Zeit, ja,
hab ich gesagt, weißt du was, ich geh einfach nicht mehr hin.
Und mach stattdessen, ratet mal, was ich stattdessen gemacht hab.
Also ich hab, wie gesagt, ich hab hier die Ausbildung gemacht.
Mit der Buchhalternase.
Und da bin ich dann nicht mehr hingegangen.
Und ratet mal, was ich gemacht habe, anstatt dahin zu gehen.
MMO gegrindet, richtig.
Richtig.
Ich bin dann einfach nicht mehr hin, hab MMO gegrindet.
Und das stimmt übrigens gar nicht, weil ich euch erzählt hab.
Dann musste ich zu dem Kurs.
Dann musste ich, war da gar nicht mehr, stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Dann hab ich MMO gegrindet.
Also ich hab richtig, ich hab richtige, ich hab damals fast, fast richtige Harzerlaufbahn eingeschlagen.
Das ist so wie Hardware-Rad.
Gut, bei dem ist ja auch noch Running Gag mit Harzer.
So.
Und dann, also wo ich die Kurve gekriegt hab, war folgendes.
Ich hab dann Zivildienst gemacht.
Da hatte ich auch überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Weil ich wollte lieber MMO grinden, anstatt Zivildienst machen.
Aber als ich Zivildienst gemacht hab, muss ich sagen,
ich hab das ja in einer Behindertenwerkstatt gemacht.
Da muss ich sagen, ich hab zwei, ich wusste zwei Sachen danach.
Ich möchte erstens, nie wieder was mit BWL machen.
Und zweitens möchte ich nie im sozialen, in irgendwelchen sozialen Berufen mit Menschen arbeiten müssen.
Das war mir klar nach den zwei Sachen.
Also ich hasse BWL und ich mag keine Leute.
So, das hab ich dann mal im Zivildienst gemerkt.
Obwohl ich sagen muss, dass der Zivildienst an sich nicht verkehrt war.
Also ich muss echt sagen, im Nachhinein war das eines der einschneidendsten Erfahrungen,
die ich gemacht hab, Zivildienst in einer Behindertenwerkstatt.
Da hat man komplett andere Welt mitbekommen, als das, was man normalerweise mitbekommt.
Und ich bin bis heute der Meinung, es wird viel zu wenig Geld dafür ausgegeben.
Für diesen Bereich.
Die Leute haben halt auch keine Lobby in dem Sinn.
Juckt, juckt keinen.
Ja, das war übrigens, da gab es übrigens das schlechteste Mittagessen, was ich je gegessen hab.
Die haben, die haben die jetzt übertrieben gesagt, die Reste von einem Krankenhaus bekommen.
Also die hatten so einen Catering Service, der hat ihnen quasi die Reste vom Krankenhaus gegeben.
Also nicht die Reste, die das Krankenhaus übrig gelassen hat, sondern die Reste,
die bei diesem Catering Service hergestellt wurden, die zu viel waren wie fürs Krankenhaus.
Also die haben für das Krankenhaus Essen gemacht, haben zu viel gemacht.
Immer, und das hat man dann dort bekommen.
Und das war so ein dermaßen schlechtes Essen.
Ähm, richtig, richtig abartig.
Und ich hab dann richtig den, den, den, den, den Five-Hat-Move der Five-Hat-Moves gemacht.
Da bin ich heute, da bin ich heute noch begeistert von.
Wobei ich sagen muss, das war eher aus Versehen.
Und zwar dort, wo ich, wie gesagt, ich hab in einer behinderten Werkstatt mein Zivilismus gemacht.
Und dort gab's halt so diese normalen Sachen mit, ähm, halt in der Gruppe mit den Menschen
irgendwelche, also mit irgendwelchen, irgendwelche organisatorischen Sachen machen
und mit den ganzen Leuten, die da sind, zusammen die betreuen, mit denen in Anführungsstrichen arbeiten.
Man, die haben ja nicht wirklich gearbeitet im klassischen Sinne, wie man sich das so vorstellt.
Das war quasi, wie soll ich sagen, so betreutes, betreutes Arbeiten.
Also du hast im Endeffekt, du hast im Endeffekt, wenn du in so einer Gruppe warst,
du hast den Leuten zugeguckt beim Plastiktüten zukleben und sowas.
Das war jetzt nicht sonderlich spannend.
Ähm, manche fanden das mega erfüllend.
Hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
Also nicht, nicht, nicht Zivilleute, sondern von den, von den behinderten, die da waren.
Die fanden das richtig geil.
Da gab's welche, die haben im Akkord Plastiktüten geklebt.
Äh, das konnten die richtig krass.
Die haben, die haben quasi sich im Kreis drehen und Plastiktüten machen.
Die hatten's voll drauf.
Naja, zumindest, ähm, ich hab dann halt gemerkt, dass so Umgang mit Menschen ist nicht meins.
So, und dann hab ich folgendes gemacht.
Ich mein, es ist halt schwierig, ne?
Es ist halt schwierig, wenn man Zivildienst macht in so, in so sozialen Einrichtungen.
Und, ähm, man kommt mit Menschen nicht gut klar.
Das ist halt, das ist halt doof.
Wobei ich ohne Scheiß sagen muss, ich komme, ich bin mit den Behinderten dort in der Behindertenwerkstatt.
Ähm, deutlich besser klargekommen, als mit den normalen, in Anführung, mit den normalen Menschen.
Ja?
In Anführung, ich bin ja, mit denen bin ich viel besser klargekommen.
Bei denen wusstest du immer, was Sache ist, ja?
Er war traurig, dann war er traurig.
Dann wusstest du, was Sache ist.
Er war sauer, dann war er sauer.
Da wusstest du auch, was Sache ist.
Und dementsprechend konntest du da auch drauf reagieren.
Ja?
Und das war halt, das war halt richtig, teilweise so richtig, wie sagt man, so herzerwärmend.
So irgendwie, der eine ist traurig, ne?
Da sag ich nur, was ist denn, was ist denn los?
Und dann sagt der irgendwie, keine Ahnung.
Die waren ja dann traurig wegen Dingern, die man als, so normalerweise gar nicht nachvollziehen kann, ja?
Der stand halt da und hat geheult und sonst wie.
Und dann hat er gesagt, na, was ist denn los?
Und da haben die dir dann so Dinge erzählt wie, er hat heute Morgen seinen Socken nicht gefunden.
So Dinge.
Oder die Mama war sauer, weil er immer die Blumenvasen runterwirft und sowas hat der eine immer erzählt.
Und da hab ich ihm dann ein bisschen doofes Zeugs erzählt.
Das fand er witzig und da war er wieder gut drauf.
Das war super, ja?
Der eine hat gesagt, ich bin traurig, weil irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ich hab nicht meine Lieblingsjacke oder sowas.
Da hab ich gesagt, hier, komm, wir gehen mal suchen, wir gehen mal suchen.
Da haben wir dann ein bisschen gesucht.
Und dann war er wieder happy.
Richtig geil eigentlich.
Also das war eigentlich eine super Geschichte.
Zumindest hab ich dann den Five-Hat-Move gemacht.
Und ich wusste ja, dass ich mit den normalen Leuten da nicht so gut klarkomme.
Und ich irgendwie die, ich weiß nicht, neun Monate oder so, wie lang das?
Zehn Monate, zehn Monate war das, glaub ich, zivilienst.
Und ich wusste, ich wusste das irgendwie rumkriegen.
Ich wusste das irgendwie aushalten.
Und dann hab ich folgendes gemacht.
Ich hab gesagt, okay, ich mach einfach mittags mit den Leuten in der Sporthalle ein bisschen Action.
Das war super, weil da hatte man welche, die waren halt übelst hyperaktiv.
Also wenn du Leute hast, die so hyperaktiv sind, wenn du die in der Gruppe sitzen hast, die geben halt keinen Ruh.
Und da bin ich mit noch jemand anderem einfach, sind wir mittags dann in der Sporthalle mit denen einfach ein bisschen rumgerannt, haben die Fußball spielen lassen.
Die haben sich dann teilweise auch gekloppt.
Da musste man sie mal ein bisschen auseinander machen und so, dann war gut.
Aber ansonsten war das super.
Und die anderen haben sich auch alle gefreut, weil die Leute dann nicht mehr so hyperaktiv waren, wenn sie aus der Sporthalle gekommen sind.
Die haben dann mittags, naja gut, das ging da relativ schnell, ne.
Der eine kannte halbwegs Fußballregeln und hat gesagt, hier Tor, ich krieg jetzt den Ball.
Und der andere hat gesagt, kriegst du nicht.
Kriegst keinen Ball.
Und da hat er den Ball genommen, sich unter das Hemd gesteckt und hat gesagt, geh weg, du kriegst den Ball nicht.
Und dann kam der andere an und hat gesagt, du gibst mir jetzt den Ball und hat ihm auf die Backe gehauen.
Und dann ging es halt los.
Das ist halt wie im Kindergarten gewesen irgendwo, ja.
Das ging halt voll zur Sache.
Da musstest du dann sagen, hier kommt mal, ich hab noch einen Ball für dich, nimm du auch mal ein.
Da hat man auch wirklich was gelernt, ohne Scheiße, hat man wirklich ein bisschen was im Umgang mit Leuten gelernt.
Zumindest so auf diesem Level.
War eigentlich eine coole Sache.
Zumindest, ich hab mir den einfach mittags, mittags immer mit jemand anderem zusammen mittags in der Sporthalle rumrennen lassen.
Das war toll.
Und dann hab ich einfach die restliche Zeit, weil das Mittagessen, also Frühstück und Mittagessen war halt so gestaffelt,
dass es im Prinzip immer über vier Stunden ging.
Also quasi eine Stunde die, eine Stunde die, dann irgendwie zwei, drei Stunden arbeiten, dann Mittagessen, eine Stunde die, eine Stunde die.
Es ging über vier Stunden.
Also im Prinzip hab ich das so gemacht, ich hab mittags mit denen in der Sporthalle ein bisschen Fußball gespielt.
Und Frühstück und Mittagessen hab ich mich an den Kiosk gesetzt.
Die hatten da so einen Kiosk.
Und hab den Zeug verkauft.
Also verkauft.
Da hast du dann also nicht wirklich verkauft.
Ich hab mich da hingesetzt und da kam dann einer an und hat gesagt, hier, ich hätt gern hier irgendwie eine Sprite gegeben,
50 Cent kassiert und gut war.
Ich hab dann quasi ganzen Tag im Kiosk gesessen und mittags mit denen in der Halle ein bisschen Fußball gespielt.
Das war äußerst entspannt, nachdem ich diesen Rhythmus so hatte für den Zivildienst.
Und ich muss halt sagen, in der Zeit hab ich ultra viel gefressen, weil, Leute, sitzt mal vier Stunden am Tag in so einem Kiosk.
Da stöpft ihr euch voll mit Leinen, Maß und Snickers und Happeneis und alles.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, davon hat man nichts geholt.
Das hat ja der Firma da gehört, also der Werkstatt, das Zeug, was sie da eingekauft haben.
Ja, das war schon cool.
Tja, und danach hab ich Physi gelernt.
Und dann hab ich, also ich glaub im zweiten Ausbildungsjahr oder so hab ich dann aufgehört, MMO Kreiselcrime zu machen.
War das Game, da war auch die Luft raus.
Ja, ich kenn das Problem, ich kenn das Problem.
So, moin moin, ich hoffe mal auf die schwere Intelligenz.
Oh, ich weiß nicht, ob es dafür genug Subs gegeben hat heute schon mal.
Kann jemand was zum Visualisieren von Daten empfehlen?
Hab über einen Web Scraper über ein Jahr eine Skala eins bis zehn und die Anzahl der abgegebenen Stimmen ausgelesen, würde dir gerne einfach...
Ähm, in welchem Format hast du die Daten denn?
Willst du was, willst du was haben, was permanent aktualisiert wird?
Oder einmal Datensatz und dazu eine Grafik generieren?
Hydrolyzer, Dankeschön für Prime Sub.
Also für eine einmalige Sache ist Excel, wenn man da nicht ne totale Abneigung dagegen hat, tatsächlich gar nicht so doof.
Auf der anderen Seite würde ich sagen, wenn du die in irgendeiner Art und Weise in einem Format vorlegen hast, was Grafana oder...
Warte mal, war das jetzt noch die Antwort?
Oder sowas in der Richtung verarbeiten kann, würde ich das vorziehen?
Stinkdrehtager, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Excellent Subscription, Leute, ich mach mal kurz nen Update.
Uiuiui, was ist hier los?
Hihappen, Dankeschön, 18 Monate Hyper-Subscription.
Kannst du dieses Job-Angebot im nächsten Video anschauen?
Okay, Moment, mach ich jetzt.
Und im nächsten Video wahrscheinlich auch.
Oh, was ist das denn?
Infrar!
Infrarstructure-Engineer gesucht.
Bisschen Paints-Champ ist das schon.
Du bist Spezialist in für Cloud-Infrastructure aus Hamburg und Umgebung.
Du möchtest ein Saas-Produkt.
Oh, das klingt aber schon ganz schön ähnlich wie Corona hier.
Auf eine hochverfügbare Infrastruktur.
Dann könnte dir unsere Pirate-Chip-Crew gefallen, wen wir suchen.
Wir halten Ausschau nach Piratinnen.
Oh, Paints-Chip nach Piraten, Alter.
Mit dem Schwerpunkt Infrastructure, langjährige Erfahrung auf See ist hilfreich.
Kann aber...
Ja, an sich passt das ja, was die haben wollen.
Ja, okay, okay.
Also, dieses Thema ist vielleicht ein bisschen zum Fremdschämen, aber ist doch ganz gut gemacht.
Nein, keine Ahnung.
Nichts.
Ich hab alles mir angeguckt, was die Leute geschrieben haben.
Ein paar, hätte ich gesagt, könnten es so von der Optik her sein, aber wenn ich danach geguckt habe, wie die heißen und so,
haben der Name nicht gestimmt und sie waren zu jung.
Welche Hardware würdest du für einen kleinen Home-Sofer empfehlen?
Für Home Assistant, OpenVPN, ein bisschen Datenspeicher aktuell.
Kannst du benutzen, ja.
Also, wenn dir dieser Aspekt hier wichtig ist, dass so ein Ordnungsgerät,
Festplatten, Vollverschlüsselung, ordentliche Geschwindigkeit, dann kein Raspberry Pi.
Aber ansonsten, für den Rest kannst du ohne Probleme einen Raspberry Pi verwenden.
Ah, das muss auch nicht sein, nee.
Hydrolyzer, langeschön, Prime Sub, Massive, Huge Subscription.
Langeschön, Prime Sub, Massive, Huge Subscription.
Euch hab ich, glaub ich, schon vorgelesen.
Was würdest du für eine kleine Web GUI-Config verwenden?
Du meinst jetzt Backend oder was?
Frontend Vue.js, stimmt für alles Vue.js mittlerweile, weil es einfach...
Moment. Weil es für mich am einfachsten ist.
Ja, ich find's schon, ich find's schon. Kann man machen.
Was denn?
CSV, Force eigentlich nur auswertend.
Na, okay, okay, also ganz ehrlich, wenn du es in der CSV hast, so dumm es jetzt klingt,
und Leute, ihr wisst, dass ich kein Fan davon bin.
Aber wenn du es in der CSV hast, ist Excel, glaub ich, gar nicht so schlecht.
Da kannst du es einfach importieren, markieren und dir was generieren lassen.
Wenn du es natürlich interaktiver haben willst, in der Webseite,
dann würde ich was anderes nehmen.
Wenn es noch deutlich mehr wird oder das permanent weiter geupdatet wird,
könnte man sich auch überlegen, ob man das nicht in eine Influx DB macht
und dann Grafana nimmt oder sowas.
Aber das Einfachste ist definitiv CSV in Excel.
Wenn du was anderes haben willst, du kannst auch eine Programmiersprache deiner Wahl nehmen,
mit irgendeiner schönen Craft Library, das importieren.
Aber das Einfachste dürfte wahrscheinlich echt Excel sein,
auch so kacke ich Excel finde.
Darf ich mich als Raub kopieren? Das müsste man dir echt mal fragen.
So nach dem Motto, da bin ich ja mal gespannt, was die zu sagen wird.
Die müsste man echt anschreiben.
Ich bin schon seit über 15 Jahren auf See.
Angefangen mit Kopieren von CDs, Brenninfrastructure.
Das mal gucken, was die schreiben.
Wahrscheinlich verstehen sie den Witz sogar.
Das ist auch nicht schlecht.
Ja, kann ich. Wahrscheinlich.
Aber jetzt nicht einfach so aus dem Steg reifen.
Das ist das, wo man die Ringe aufeinander legen muss, oder?
Ich weiß das gar nicht aus dem Kopf.
Das ist doch das, wo man diese drei Stäbe hat
und dann die unterschiedlich großen Ringe drauf legen muss.
Und man immer nur das obere runternehmen kann.
Warum an Jaro? Weil es nice ist.
Was hast du für einen VM-Workflow?
Ich habe hier eine VM laufen und hier Windows.
Also ich habe auf dem zweiten Desktop einfach VM-Workstation laufen.
Zweiter Windows-Desktop, VM-Workstation, kann einfach mit Shortcut rüber.
Raw Crafts I.O.
Kenne ich nicht.
Aber der Serious Max hat Ahnung, das weiß ich.
Der kennt sich mit Frontend aus.
Ich habe schon ein paar coole Proof of Concept Frontends gebastelt, die nice sind.
Der weiß, was er macht.
Wann bauen wir das Traffic Let's Encrypt Konstrukt aus dem Stream
neulich auf Kubernetes mit all garnicht?
Der Sinn von diesem Traffic Let's Encrypt Konstrukt war, dass es easy ist.
Und man das mit paar Zeilen Jaml einfach machen kann.
Was ist eigentlich deine Lieblingsbackendsprache für Webseiten?
Also meine Lieblingssprache früher.
Hättest du mich das vor 5, 6 Jahren gefragt, hätte ich gesagt, ganz klar, Ruby on Rails.
Aber jetzt ASP.NET Core.
PHP.
Hey, PHP ist garnicht schlecht.
PHP mit Laravel oder so ist garnicht schlecht.
Kann man wirklich verwenden.
Hast du einen Tipp, wie man am besten mit stinkfauen Kollegen in der Arbeit fertig wird?
Inwiefern?
Du meinst Leute, die einfach nix machen?
Also mich interessiert eigentlich garnicht, ob Leute großartig was machen oder nicht.
Was mich stört sind Leute, wenn ich auf die warten muss.
Also wenn Leute, wenn ich auf Leute warten muss, geht mir das auf den Sack.
Wenn andere einfach nur lahm sind, ist mir das egal.
Ansonsten einfach auch nix machen, wenn man das kann.
Nee, aber mich nervt es nicht.
Mich nervt es immer nur, wenn ich auf die Leute warten muss.
Und dann nerv ich die Leute ein bisschen.
Und wenn sie dann auch genervt sind, irgendwann muss es dann halt mal deinem Chef sagen.
Aber ich würde jetzt nicht da gleich hinrennen.
Sonst hat er ja auch keinen Bock drauf, sich mit dem ganzen Tag mit so Zeug auseinanderzusetzen.
Und manche Leute checken es auch einfach nicht.
Oftmals liegt es ja daran, dass zumindest habe ich den Eindruck.
Ich sage jetzt einfach mal meine persönliche Erfahrung und persönlichen Eindruck.
Manchmal ist es gar nicht so, oder oftmals habe ich den Eindruck, ist es gar nicht so,
dass die Leute einfach nur stinkfauen sind.
Viele Leute versuchen damit zu umgehen, also mit nichts machen, quasi darüber hinwegzutäuschen,
dass sie eigentlich garnicht wissen, was sie machen.
Wir hatten zum Beispiel auch jemand, der sollte sich um Mail-Sachen kümmern.
Und der war auch unglaublich langsam mit allem immer.
Bis ich dann irgendwann mal drauf gekommen bin, der weiß einfach nicht, was er macht.
Und war auch immer übelst pissed, wenn du ihn gefragt hast.
Das weiß ich auch warum, der wollte einfach nicht zugeben, dass er keine Ahnung hat.
Ich finde zugeben, wenn man keine Ahnung hat, gar nicht so problematisch,
solange man nicht von allem keine Ahnung hat.
Ich sage das mittlerweile auch.
Also ich habe da mittlerweile keine Schmerzen damit, wenn mir da irgendeiner ankommt
und erstmal 80 Buzzwords erzählt und jetzt denkt, man müsste verstehen, was er gesagt hat.
Ist ja keine Probleme mehr mittlerweile mit nachzufragen.
Oder auch, wenn einer aus einem komplett anderen Gebiet kommt und da was runter rattert in 5 Minuten.
Okay, weiter. Ja, was sagt mir das jetzt?
Wenn man natürlich von nichts eine Ahnung hat, ist das auch doof.
Vor allem bei Workstation vs. Virtual Box, ganz klar vor allem bei Workstation.
Meilenweit.
Ich habe mir noch nie ein Business Notebook gekauft.
Ich hatte 3 Stück.
Äh, stimmt nicht. Doch, doch stimmt.
3 verschiedene Marken.
Das ist Lenovo-IBM früher, dann Dell und dann Fujitsu Siemens.
Aber wir haben eigentlich zum größten Teil IBM-Lenovo gehabt.
Und damit war ich eigentlich ganz zufrieden.
Wobei ich sagen muss, dass mir die alten Thinkpads besser gefallen haben,
weil die auch Metall Scharniere hatten.
Was? Security Certification Progress Chart.
Leute, wir fangen gleich mit den Schriftarten an.
Wir haben heute massig Zeit.
Was bin ich sehend? Was ist das?
Alter, mehr Abkürzung, please.
Abkürzung.
Was ist denn das?
Ich bin triggert, allein schon durch die Name.
Was ist CISM, Alter?
So geht es ja nicht hier.
Also, ISSEP, ISSMP, CNDA, CISA, GSSP.NET, CSPSM, SAP, SCP, VCP.
Ach du große Hörer, was ist denn das alles?
ITIL Foundation.
Oh, Paints Champ, ich hör mal bloß auf.
Also das einzige, was ich jemals gehört habe, ist in diesem ganzen Ding ist ITIL.
Was zum Geier ist denn der?
Was ist denn der Zachmann 1?
Und ansonsten vielleicht...
Das CCI, das kenne ich auch, das sagt mir auch noch was.
Das ist der Cisco Certified.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es Internet Engineer ist.
Aber sowas in der Richtung.
Was ist CCI?
Internet, ja okay, fast.
Fast, Internetwork Expert, fast.
Da vor diesem AWS und Azure Zeug habe ich auch schon mal was gehört.
Aber der Rest, Alter...
Cloud Plus?
Nee, sagt mir zum größten Teil nichts.
Solang es ein gutes Game ist, warum nicht?
Ah, Kollege, der zu faul ist, den Bug zu fixen, dann muss ich es mal...
Nö, das würde ich nicht machen.
Also wenn das ganz klar sein Verantwortungsbereich ist, das zu machen, dann würde ich nicht für ihn fixen.
Dann würde ich einfach auch nichts machen und sagen, ich warte drauf, dass es gefixt ist.
Ich warte schon seit 5 Tagen, ich kann nichts machen.
Man kann es ihm ja mal sagen, aber irgendwann...
Es hilft ja nichts, wenn man das dann alles macht, dann hast du doppelt Arbeit.
Dann musst du dein Kram machen plus sein Kram machen und er kriegt auch noch Geld für.
Das ist ja auch nicht den Zweck der Sache.
Einfach Hardcore ablösten 24 7.
Nee, also...
Ich habe überhaupt kein Problem damit, wenn es Leute gibt, die keine Ahnung haben.
Es gibt zwei Fälle, wo es mich nervt.
Es ist überhaupt kein Problem, wenn jemand in einem Gebiet keine Ahnung hat.
Also der erste Fall ist, wenn er externer Consultant ist, der dafür eingekauft wurde und keine Ahnung hat
und dafür irgendwie 150k im Jahr kassiert, keine Ahnung zu haben.
Das habe ich ein Problem damit.
Und das nächste ist, was mich nervt ist, wenn die Leute keine Ahnung haben und nicht wollen.
Also sprich, es gibt Leute, zum Beispiel,
ich erzähle euch jetzt mal was, der ist mittlerweile nicht mehr bei uns,
aber das ist Live-Erfahrung von der Arbeit.
Ihr wisst ja, dass ich mich um unsere Git-Repos kümmere.
So mit Feature-Requests und Dinger-Merchen und Taggen und neue Releases pushen und solche Dinger.
Ich habe da mal ein Video drüber gemacht.
Wer genau wissen will, was ich mache, kann sich das hier angucken.
Ich habe nicht viele Vorgaben, weil ich bin eigentlich ein Fan davon,
dass die Leute ihren persönlichen Workflow machen können, wie sie wollen,
solange sie sich an ein paar Sachen halten.
Zum Beispiel habe ich, und die meisten Sachen sind ja gar nicht, weil ich es irgendwie geil finde,
sondern weil sich das mit der Zeit beseitigt.
Zum Beispiel, wenn einer einen Feature-Branche macht,
dann finde ich es gut, wenn man den mit seinem Kürzel macht,
dass ich weiß, von wem der ist.
Ansonsten muss ich dann halt nachgucken, wer hat da die meisten Comets drin gemacht oder sonst was.
Und noch besser ist, wenn in dem Feature-Branche eine Ticket-Nummer drin steht.
Es ist jetzt nicht, wo ich mich wahnsinnig darüber aufrege, wenn es nicht der Fall ist,
aber ich finde es zumindest gut.
Das ist das Erste, ich habe auch solche Videos gemacht,
da steht unter anderem drin, Feature-Branches, bitte mit Namenskürzel,
und wenn es geht, Ticket im Namen machen, dass ich gleich sehe, wozu es gehört.
Und noch ein weiterer Punkt ist, wenn ein Merch-Request gemacht wird,
dann bitte, wenn es ein Ticket gibt, das verlinken und drunter schreiben,
ob mit diesem Change, wenn es ein Merch-Request gibt,
und drunter schreiben, ob mit diesem Change irgendwelche zusätzlichen Arbeiten verbunden sind.
Also es gibt ja zum Beispiel Changes, dann musst du parallel noch irgendwas anderes machen.
Also die einfachste Beispiel ist für Anwendungen oder was auch immer,
irgendwas erwartet, dass Datenbank eine gewisse Struktur hat
und du musst vorher erst eine Datenbank-Migration machen, dass das funktioniert.
Also sprich, man soll, wenn man irgendwie ein neues Feature committet,
reinschreiben, wenn dazu noch irgendwelche To-Do's erforderlich sind,
die nicht derjenige quasi selbst damit jetzt gemacht hat.
Weil es kann ja sein, dass wenn das ausgerollt wird,
und die Leute, die dann nachts da sitzen und das Ganze ausrollen,
die haben ja keine Ahnung davon, was der sich gedacht hat, als er den Gramm programmiert hat.
Das heißt, ich mache dann auch einen Change-Log drüber, wo dann drinne steht, hier Achtung,
wenn man das und das ausrollt, dann bitte darauf achten, dass man danach guckt,
dass, keine Ahnung, die Container neu gestartet werden auf dem Host oder sowas.
So als Beispiel.
Und das ist eigentlich mehr oder weniger alles, was ich haben will für Feature-Requests.
Das ist jetzt nichts wahnsinnig Kompliziertes.
Und damit ich das automatisch machen kann, ich mache den Gramm ja,
ihr wisst ja, ich bin faul as fuck, was sowas angeht, ich mache das ja automatisch.
Also auch zum größten Teil Change-Log erstellen und sonst was, ich editiere da nur,
bei jedem neuen Release gehe ich da mal drüber und editiere ein paar Sachen,
die total wir geschrieben sind, sodass es Sinn ergibt und gut ausschaut.
Aber das meiste lasse ich automatisch machen.
Ich habe da einen Skript, das mercht und das trägt die Sachen ins Change-Log ein
und paste den neuen To-Do's in ein Auftragsticket rein über die Jira-AP und sowas.
Das ist eigentlich ganz gut, finde ich zumindest, ganz gut durchdacht.
Und damit das funktioniert, müssen sich die Leute nur noch an den dritten Punkt halten,
und zwar, wenn ein Merchrequest aufgemacht wird,
dann muss in dem Titel das nach einem gewissen Schema sein.
Und zwar das erste ist, wenn es ein Ticket gibt, muss das Ticket da stehen,
dann muss ein Pipe-Zeichen kommen, ich habe irgendein Trend-Zeichen gebraucht,
ich hätte auch ein Semikolon, Komma oder irgendwas nehmen können,
aber ich habe mal einen Pipe genommen, also Ticket, Pipe, Titel vom Feature,
also sowas wie LED blinkt jetzt rot, einfach random ausgedacht,
also man würde dann schreiben Ticket Nummer 1, 2, 3, Pipe, LED blinkt jetzt rot, Pipe,
und dann ob es zusätzliche Arbeitsschritte gibt, Pipe ist das Zeichen hier,
und dann ob es zusätzliche To-Do's gibt, also ein Merchrequest,
das sich dann automatisch merchen kann, sieht bei uns so aus, Ticket, 1, 2, 3, 4, LED ist jetzt rot,
ist der Name von dem Feature, und dann muss man reinschreiben, sowas.
So, das ist alles, mehr muss man nicht machen.
Das kriegt auch jeder hin, das kriegt jeder hin,
bis auf den einen, den wir mal da hatten, der hat es ums Verrecken nicht hinbekommen.
Und zwar, und zwar, er wollte nicht, der wollte nicht, der hat mich ohnemals jedes Mal,
oder zu fast jedem Merchrequest hat er mich angerufen,
ja, Max, sag mal, wie muss ich das da jetzt eintragen, dass das alles funktioniert?
So, die ersten 5 Mal habe ich ihm das noch erklärt, wir haben das auch zusammen gemacht,
und ich habe ihm dann den Link zum Dokument geschickt,
wo ich reingeschrieben habe, was er machen muss, so.
Und, aber irgendwann, so nach dem 20. Mal, hatte ich keinen Bock mehr.
Da hatte ich echt keinen Nerven mehr drauf.
Und das Schlimme war, das war, kennt ihr Leute, die nicht nur keinen Bock haben,
oder unbelehrbar sind, sondern die danach auch noch übelst so pissig sind, die ganze Zeit?
Also der hat da nicht nur angerufen und hat gesagt, hier, wie mache ich denn das jetzt?
Der hat dann quasi angerufen und so nach dem Motto, ja, wie mache ich denn da jetzt diese komischen Git-Geschichten?
Das versteht auch keiner, da ging das dann die ganze Zeit so weiter.
Und das geht mir so auf den Sack.
Also wie gesagt, das sind die 2 Sachen, die mir auf den Keks gehen.
Leute, die konsultant für ein Thema sind, keine Ahnung haben und 150k im Jahr dafür kassieren,
und Leute, die es nicht wollen.
Das nervt mich.
Ohne Scheiß, ich bin der Meinung, faule Leute haben, und da könnt ihr mir mal eure Meinung zu sagen,
oder ob ihr das seht, faule Leute entwickeln die besten Lösungen.
Warum? Weil sie sich am besten oder im besten Fall nie wieder damit beschäftigen wollen
und das deswegen so bauen, dass es gut durchdacht ist, möglichst einfach ist und gut funktioniert.
Faule Leute, deswegen sind faule Führungskräfte auch das Beste.
So dumm es klingt, faule Führungskräfte sind super.
Faule Führungskräfte sorgen dafür, dass das ordentlich delegiert wird an die richtigen Leute,
die richtigen Sachen, so vorbereitet, dass die Leute es machen können,
dass sie nie wieder was von hören, dass es einfach funktioniert.
Faule Chefs sind im Prinzip das Beste, was man haben kann.
Was ich, ich will damit nicht sagen, dass man, falls er zuguckt, ne.
Also ich weiß, der guckt manchmal jetzt nicht, was ich nicht sagen will ist, dass man Chef faul ist.
Das ist eigentlich das Beste, was einem passieren kann.
Es gibt, es gab, ich hab letztens mal einen Talk gesehen.
Ich hab letztens mal einen Talk gesehen, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das noch hinbekomme.
Das war ein richtig, das war ein richtig guter Vortrag.
Der hat gesagt, es gibt Leute, mal gucken, ob ich diese Tabelle jetzt hinbekomme.
Der hat gesagt, es gibt, es gibt quasi so vier Kategorien von Leuten.
Und zwar, es gibt, warte mal, wir machen das Massive Markdown Table.
Markdown Tables Generator, wunderbar, oh ja, exzellent.
Ne, ne, egal, es geht ja auch nicht.
Also es gibt, es gibt vier, es gibt vier Orten von Leuten.
Es gibt Leute, die sind, okay, warte mal, es gibt Leute, die sind motiviert und es gibt Leute, die sind faul.
Ich hab das letztens in einem Webcast oder in einem Konferenztalk gesehen, war richtig, richtig gute, richtig gute Idee von dem Kerl.
Also es gibt Leute, die sind motiviert und es gibt Leute, die sind faul.
So, es gibt Leute, die haben Ahnung und es gibt Leute, die sind planlos.
So, und jetzt, und jetzt gibt es da die, jetzt gibt es da die Kombination oder jetzt unterschiedlich, unterschiedlich schlimmen, schlimmen Kombinationen.
Also es gibt den, der faul und planlos ist, das ist nicht so schlimm, davon kann man auch ein paar Leute gebrauchen.
Der macht wenigstens nichts kaputt, weil er ist planlos, aber er macht auch nichts.
Das ist, das ist auch okay, da geht nichts, da geht nichts, da geht nichts schief, ja.
Dann gibt es Leute, die sind, die sind, die haben Ahnung, aber sind faul.
Das sind optimale Chefs, das sind optimale Chefs oder was haben wir, Führungskräfte.
Gut, das war natürlich ein bisschen lustig gemeint dieser Vortrag, ja.
Also es gibt Leute, die sind, die haben Ahnung, sind aber faul.
Die entwickeln super Lösungen, weil sie sich nie wieder damit beschäftigen wollen.
Dann gibt es Leute, die sind motiviert und haben Ahnung, die sind motiviert und haben Ahnung.
Davon gibt es nur ganz wenige, das sind die absoluten Premium-Leute, da muss man sich wirklich, äh, du musst motiviert einrücken.
Ah ja, stimmt, hast recht, ich muss motiviert einrücken.
Genau, so.
Dann gibt es welche, die sind, die haben Ahnung, sind motiviert.
Die muss man sich wirklich warm halten, die Leute.
Also, davon gibt es nicht viele und das sind wirklich die Besten, die man bekommen kann.
Ähm, wobei die sich oftmals in Perfektionismus quasi verlieren.
Also, die sind super motiviert und haben auch Ahnung, brauchen aber teilweise lange dafür irgendwas zu machen.
So, und dann hast du das Schlimmste.
Also, es ging darum, welche Leute man einstellen kann.
Das war so leicht humoristisch angehauchter Talk, ja.
Der hat gemeint, den kannst du einstellen, faul und planlos, kein Problem.
Ja, der sorgt unter anderem vielleicht auch für bessere Moral in der Gruppe, weil er lustig ist oder so.
Äh, wunderbar, kann man machen.
Äh, faul und Ahnung sind wunderbare Führungskräfte, weil sie super delegieren können.
Motiviert und Ahnung gibt es ganz selten.
Muss man sich auf jeden Fall warm halten, auch alles einstellen.
Aber, was du auf gar keinen Fall einstellen darfst, meinte er in diesem Talk,
sind Leute, die motiviert sind und planlos, weil die machen dir alles kaputt.
Die machen dir alles kaputt?
Die haben keine Ahnung, was sie machen, aber davon machen sie viel.
Wie gesagt, der Talk war ein bisschen auf lustig gemacht, aber so blöd fand ich die Idee von dem Kerl gar nicht.
Ich meine, es ist ja logisch.
Jemand, der keine Ahnung hat, aber noch viel macht, dann ist die Kacke am Dampfen.
Ja, und ich glaube, so jemand war das.
Der ist planlos und motiviert und macht was, aber ist nervig gewesen einfach.
Na gut.
Vielleicht ist das ja so jemand.
Er schreibt hier, ich habe auch einen Kollegen, der eigentlich motiviert ist, aber nicht wirklich selbstständig die anderen sieht und sich ungern Aufgaben zuteilen lässt von einem Nicht-Chef.
Ach so, na gut, das ist ja was anderes.
Übrigens, das finde ich gar nicht so übel.
Ich muss mal ehrlich gestehen, an der Stelle, ich habe auch nicht gerne zu viele Themen, wo ich jetzt wirklich viel Verantwortung habe.
Ich mache lieber bei Sachen mit.
Also ich kümmere mich lieber um gute technische Lösungen als um organisatorische Sachen drum herum.
Deswegen ist es mir lieber, als hat jemand anderes den Hut auf, aber ich mache mit und sorge dafür, dass es gut wird.
Ist mir persönlich lieber.
Ich bin nicht so der Organisations-Fan.
Und ich arbeite ehrlich gesagt auch lieber mit Leuten zusammen an Problemen als alleine.
Klingt jetzt blöd.
Also wenn es was wirklich kompliziertes ist.
Klingt jetzt blöd, weil ihr wisst ja, ich habe schon oft genug gesagt, ich mag andere Menschen nicht.
Aber Leute, Leute, die ähnlich ticken wie ich, das ist was anderes.
Aber wenn es so Sachen gibt, die länger dauern und ein bisschen kompliziert sind.
Aber jetzt nicht so, dass du den ganzen Tag Big Brain machen musst, wo auch ein paar längere Strecken, ein paar nervige Aufgaben dabei sind.
Dann mache ich die am liebsten mit anderen Leuten zusammen, weil nervige Aufgaben sind nicht mehr so nervig, wenn man sie mit 2-3 Leuten machen muss.
Trackpoint ist das beste gewesen bei den alten Lenovo IBM Notebooks, wobei haben die immer noch, oder?
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Ich würde sagen, wir fangen jetzt mal langsam an.
Ich frage zwecks Backend, weil ich ein großer Fan von C-Sharp und gerne Backend schreiben würde.
Da musst du nicht confused sein.
Du kannst diesen ganzen Microsoft Shit einfach links liegen lassen.
Du machst einfach ein ganz normales ASP.NET Core Projekt Web API.
Du machst ein ganz normales Web API Projekt.
Diesen ganzen Müll kannst du machen.
Du machst ein Web API Projekt und das Razer brauchst du nicht, Razer brauchst du nicht, Razer ist Server.
Also die Microsoft Technologie ist folgendes.
Razer ist Server gerendertes HTML.
Braucht man nicht, macht man eigentlich heute kaum noch.
Blazer ist kleinzeitiges.NET WebAssembly oder über eine ganz komische Signal-A-Verbindung auf dem Server benutzt auch kein Mensch.
Sag ich jetzt einfach mal.
Vielleicht benutzt das doch mittlerweile jemand, keine Ahnung.
Und MVC ist eigentlich so der Standard Web API Ding.
Der Schwachsinn. Stimmt doch gar nicht.
MVC ist Razer Pages mit Model View Controller.
Du machst ein ganz normales ASP.NET Web API Projekt. Fertig.
Den restlichen Kram kannst du komplett ignorieren.
Und das war's.
Du machst ein Web API Projekt, da bekommst du im Endeffekt eine Startdatei, wo du deine Datenbank, deine Datenbank Migrations reinmachst und Services registrierst.
Und du machst ein paar Controller, wo du dann Rest API Web Requests hinschicken kannst. Fertig.
So und noch nicht einmal das musst du verwenden. Du kannst auch sowas wie GraphQL oder so verwenden.
Das ist wirklich confusing, dass Microsoft so viele Sachen anbietet.
Aber weiß ich noch nicht alles. Die haben ja auch noch Web Forms.
Hat jemand mal die Ehre gehabt, Web Forms zu machen?
Web Forms, beste.
Das ist sowas, da muss man echt einen großen Bogen drum machen.
Ja, so ungefähr mache ich das auch.
Ich lasse dann einen Changelog draus generieren.
Ich mache das in einer Markdown Datei und die Render ich dann zu HTML und füge die direkt einmal im Monat in so ein Release Ticket ein.
Das wird dann alles ersetzt und ordentlich formatiert.
Wie realistisch sind die 150K?
Wenn du der Super Big Brain Consultant bist, das ist kein Ding würde ich mal sagen.
Region und gebietsabhängig natürlich.
Die ganzen Consultants sind ja meistens auch Selbstständige, da ist das ja eh wieder was anderes.
Da musst du ja mehr verdienen.
Als Azubi ist das überhaupt kein Problem. Als Azubi ist es nicht deine Aufgabe Ahnung zu haben.
Als Azubi ist es deine Aufgabe sogar im Umkehrschluss eher noch zu sagen, wenn du keine Ahnung hast.
Also bei einem Azubi finde ich das überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Aber wenn man jemand eingekauft hat, einen externen Experten dazu auch noch, für ein Thema und der tut sich bei einfachsten Sachen im Jahr 2021 schwer.
Und nach 20 mal erklären meckert er noch rum und hat keinen Bock, dann habe ich da echt meine Zweifel dran.
Weil man muss ehrlich sagen, die grundlegende Bedienung von Git und den Basic Git Work oder Shit Workflows sollte jeder Consultant Experte wie auch immer im Jahr 2021 im Schlaf hinkriegen.
Alter die Musik! Nordas hier! Nordas Musik!
Komm mit dem Chat nicht hinterher, ich wollte jetzt eigentlich Schriftdaten machen.
Doch, doch, doch machts. Habt ihr Tipps für gute Fachliteratur? Fange bald. Nein brauchst du nicht, brauchst keine Fachliteratur.
Ganze Sachen, die es dafür gibt sind umsonst unsinnig. Was sinnvoll ist, sobald du aber mit der Ausbildung sich dem Ende nähert, mach IHK Prüfung.
Ansonsten gibt es da nichts. Guck dir lieber an, was das für eine Firma ist, wo du dann arbeitest und was die so machen.
Wenn es beispielsweise irgendeine Softwarefirma ist, die.NET Anwendungen macht, dann schadet es nichts sich ein paar.NET Tutorials anzugucken.
Ich habe früher gerne Rails benutzt, ich glaube ich habe aber seit Rails 3 oder so nichts mehr damit gemacht.
Was als Berufseinsteiger? Lieber Job der entspannt ist, wo man nichts lernt und ewig da bleibt oder etwas stressiger Job oder ein Fehler mit zum Hoppen, das ist persönliche Vorliebe.
Bei mir war das so, ich habe ja meine Ausbildung gemacht und da habe ich übrigens auch schon ein Video darüber gemacht, da kann man sich ja alles angucken.
Ich habe meine Ausbildung gemacht damals bei einem lokalen Provider und das war nicht entspannt.
Die Ausbildung war viel selbst machen, weil man keinen hatte, der sich wirklich um einen kümmert.
Danach auch noch relativ anstrengend und dann bin ich gewechselt und da wo ich jetzt bin, ist das schon ab und zu mal ein bisschen stressig, aber im Großen und Ganzen ist das durchaus in Ordnung.
Und ich bin jemand, nach 14 Jahren, ich bin lieber entspannt als gestresst und dafür nehme ich auch ein bisschen weniger Geld in Kauf.
Aber es hat ja keiner was von, wenn du nach 5 Jahren voll am Arsch bist.
Aber es ist immer ein bisschen persönliche Vorliebe.
Will eine.NET Core Web API auf einem Ubuntu Server laufen lassen? Welche Rational DB würdest du empfehlen? Wie wäre es mit SQLite? Ich höre in Postkreis kannst du machen, aber am einfachsten zum starten ist tatsächlich SQLite, so doof es klingt. Du brauchst nichts zusätzliches.
Und wenn du nicht wahnsinnig viel Multithreaden oder sowas willst, dann ist das überhaupt kein Ding. Also SQLite ist jetzt nicht langsam oder so. SQLite hat bloß Probleme bei Parallelen, bei vielen Parallelen Schreiben und sowas.
Aber ansonsten ist SQLite gar nicht verkehrt.
Und man kann halt total easy mit anfangen, weil es halt einfach nichts zusätzliches braucht.
Wenn du da jetzt natürlich mit rechnest, dass du 5000 Benutzer hast, die da zig Sachen parallel drinne machen, SQLite parallel lesen geht auch noch halbwegs, aber parallel schreiben ist halt Payne's Champ.
Also ich wäre für SQLite zum Anfang, wenn man nur nicht weiß, was da genau rauskommt.
Man kann es ja eh easy umstellen. Dadurch, dass du also EF Core oder heißt das eigentlich überhaupt noch Core Entity Framework verwendest, ist es ja total easy. Du musst ja eigentlich gar nichts machen, außer die Datenbank umstellen. Du musst ja eigentlich nichts machen, wenn du eine andere Datenbank verwenden willst.
Connection String ändern. Ja, das war's.
SQLite ist doch auch kein RDBMS wie Posco. Doch, klar. SQLite ist kein NoSQL oder sowas.
Okay, so jetzt gucken wir uns das mal mit den Fonds an. Also ich hab schon ein paar Fonds, die ich ausprobieren will.
Es gibt beispielsweise diesen JetBrains-Fond, es gibt neuen MS-Fond, dann gibt es hier ein Vierer-Code. So, sag mal, schießt mal los, Leute. Heck, kennen wir ja schon. Was gibt es noch für ein neisses Cascadia-Code, ist das neue, oder?
Ubuntu Mono meinetwegen. Meslo ist Apple, oder? Meslo ist der Apple-Fond, der ist cool. Den hatte ich auch mal eine Weile verwendet.
Guck mal, was es da so alles gibt.
114 Best Programming-Fonds. Ja, übertreib's halt. Fantastik-Sans-Nerd-Fond. Ach du Scheiße. Ja, Terminus hat eine Erfolge geschrieben. Terminus 9 Punkt. Das kenn ich, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu oldschool, ja.
Ja, bei SQLite hast du keinen Server. Das stimmt, du hast kein extra Datenbank-Prozess, aber das ist ja, also das macht es ja nicht weniger zu einer Datenbank.
Die neuen Windows-Fonds schon gesehen, ja. SQLite ist halt eine Datei unfertig. Na ja, Postgres sind auch Dateien unfertig. Das unfertig ist halt ein bisschen komplexer als unfertig.
Postgres ist ein Datei, das ist richtig. Postgres ist aber unten drunter auch nur ein paar Dateien.
Wie alt bist du denn, wenn du schon 13 Jahre bist? Ich bin 36.
Victor Mono. Moment, ist das ein Name oder ist das wirklich eine Schriftart? Das ist tatsächlich eine Schriftart. Victor Mono.
Okay, 15 Best Programming-Fonds. Input, Vierer-Code, Konsolas, Source-Code Pro. Den habe ich früher mal ganz kurz verwendet, aber der war mir zu breit. Mal gucken, ob es den Monoid...
Oh, man muss jetzt nicht übertreiben hier. Ubuntu Mono, Sudo? Es gibt Sudo-Fond, Troidsons, Roboto. Roboto ist tatsächlich ein nicer Fond.
Moment, es gibt Press, was? Press Start. Tug ernsthaft, das heißt so? Okay, das probiere ich jetzt. Das probiere ich mal aus.
Okay. Ach stimmt, IBM. Das gab es auch, das ist das neue, das ist auch relativ.
Windings. Ah, gebadet Leute, gebadet. Okay, wir fangen mal mit dem JetBrains-Fond an, weil den wollte ich schon immer mal ausprobieren. Hab ich nur nie gemacht.
Wir brauchen jetzt aber mal ein Test-Sample an Code. Fond-Test.
So, machen wir mal irgendwie ein bisschen, lass es mich ein bisschen Test-Dateien für. Ups. Machen wir irgendwie keine Index.js-Touch. Blob.cs.
So. So. Wie? Ach so, ist ja kein CR. Ja gut, da kopiere ich mir einfach ein bisschen Test-Code hier raus. Wir brauchen ja nur ein bisschen Code, dass wir dann was sehen.
Ach ja. Mal gucken, ob diese, ob die Fonds auch, wie nennt sich das denn, wenn die extra Symbole haben für kleiner gleich und ungleich und sowas. Wie heißt denn das nochmal?
Ligatures. Fuck, Alter, kann doch keiner ausspreche. Wie heißt das auf Deutsch? Liguren oder sowas wahrscheinlich. Ligatur. Ligaturen.
Scorcho, da habe ich schon 6 Monate Subscription. Massive. Exklusivatom, ist nice, dass du den W-Share gefunden hast. Hallo. Was ist hier los? Warum loadet das und wird nicht fertig?
Loading. Postchamp. Ok, bam, abbrechen. Ich brauch da einfach nur ein bisschen Test-Code hier. Ah nee, Moment. Ah, ah, geh weg. Wim, please, come on.
Warum lässt sich das net kopieren? Was ist hier los? Warum, warum, warum kann mein, warum ist mein Wim, warum ist mein Wim-Theme überhaupt kaputt?
Hä, what the, hallo? Döh, döh, döh. Warum markieren? Quote plus Y. Warum geht das net? Debated.
So, wunderbar. Super Test-Programm. So, jetzt brauchen wir noch irgendeinen JavaScript-Crap hier. Client-App, Index, was haben wir hier, Source, Main. Ja, perfekt.
So. Reicht, reicht zum Testen. Sehr schön. Data. Alles klar, so. Also, den Font, den wir hier sehen, das ist jetzt Hack. Das ist mein Lieblings-Font.
Den hab ich im Editor und den hab ich in der Kommando-Zeile. Aber den werden wir jetzt austauschen.
Font. Ja, also mein Lieblings-Font ist wirklich die letzten Jahre über schon Hack. Hack-Font. Weiß ich da mal ein bisschen mehr zu angucken will. Ja, meint das Falsche, das hier. Hack.
Beste, Hacker-Man. Hack ist wirklich Poggers, ein richtiger Poggers-Font. Moment, kann man die Fonts hier alle ausprobieren?
Das ist ja noch viel besser, da muss ich das gerade hier in diesem komischen Editor machen. Wait a minute. Das ist ja noch viel nicer. Ok, Size. Size. Bisschen größer das Ganze. 20, jawoll.
Mein Poggers ist, warum wechselst du? Ich wechsle gar nicht. Ich probiere nur ein paar Sachen aus. Es ist immer noch nicht verkehrt zu wissen, was sonst noch so abgeht. Ja, das ist cool, das gefällt mir. Das ist nice.
Wir machen hier ein bisschen weniger Ifs. Also, was haben wir hier für schöne Fonts, die wir ausprobieren wollen? Mal gucken, ob da alles drin ist.
Was ist das Stream von dir? Ja, ich habe vorhin zum ersten Mal OBS gestartet. Merkt man das? Vielleicht sind die Settings noch nicht ganz richtig.
Schön, dass du deinen V-Share gefunden hast. PufuSXL. Nice. Kappa. Ja. So.
Moment, Moment, Moment. Ich habe vergessen, wie du heißt. Ich habe es nur kurz gesehen. Das ist das, was mich im Discord so verwirrt hat. Wo im Discord auf einmal ein Mod da war mit einem Name, den ich schon nie gehört habe.
Manuel? Kann das sein? Ist das Manuel? Ich weiß es nicht. Keine Ahnung. Ich wollte gerade sagen. Lucas. Lucas. Ja, genau. Lucas M. Ich wollte gerade sagen, wer ist denn Kyoko? Ich kenne nur Lucas M, aber da ist mir der Name nicht eingefallen.
Okay, also JetBrains. Ist das JetBrains-Font hier drin? Der ist natürlich nicht drin. Wie, das ist alles, was man ausprobieren kann?
Okay, wir müssen noch ein paar Fonts selbst ausprobieren. Also Hack können wir ausprobieren. Wir können Ubuntu Mono ausprobieren. Der sieht nicht viel anders aus. Doch, sieht ziemlich anders aus.
Ich muss sagen, Hack ist wirklich ein nicer Font. Das gefällt mir besser als Ubuntu Mono. Ich glaube aber, dass Ubuntu Mono und Hack den gleichen Base-Font mal hatten vor 10 Jahren.
Sag mal, arbeitest du bei einer Bank mit einem gelben Logo? Also gelb ist im Logo teilweise drin. Aber da gibt es viele Banken, die teilweise gelb im Logo haben.
Leak. Hackweight. Vielleicht habe ich euch auch jebaited und wir haben gar kein gelb im Logo. Ihr werdet es nicht erfahren.
Man weiß es nicht. Übrigens, morgen habe ich Rücksprache mit meinem Chef. Und das ist nichts ungewöhnliches. Das haben wir einmal im Monat.
Und ich werde ihn mal fragen, ob das okay ist, wenn ich in einem Video Gehaltsleak mache. Ich weiß, dass das rein rechtlich gesehen nichts dagegen spricht.
Bevor mir das die Leute wieder erzählen. Aber ich werde das so oft gefragt, hier im Stream, unter den Videos. Und wir haben letztens in dem Video sogar gesagt, wir finden es doof, dass in Deutschland da keiner drüber spricht.
Ist doch eh Tarifvertrag. Naja, Teil davon ist Tarifvertrag. Aber es gibt ja noch Sachen, die du zusätzlich vereinbaren kannst zum Tarifvertrag.
Du kannst ja zufällig deinen Tarifvertrag und Stufe leaken. Das habe ich schon gemacht.
Das habe ich schon gemacht. Ich bin Stufe 6 mit 14 Berufsjahren oder 12. Der Tarifvertrag kann ich leaken. Das ist kein Problem.
Das ist nichts. Die Gehaltsabrechnung kann ich nicht zeigen. Das ist geschwärzt.
Ja, ich bin Stufe 6 mit 14 Berufsjahren. Also laut Tarifvertrag ist es easy. Tarifvertrag bin ich Stufe 6 mit 14 Berufsjahren.
Ich mache das aber nicht schon 14 Jahre. Aber die haben mir das vorher angerechnet. Ich mache das erst 13 Jahre.
Das ist jetzt kein Chebat. Also das ist wirklich so.
Und da kommt bei mir noch ein bisschen was drauf. Leider haben sie das bisschen was noch ein bisschen mehr noch nicht unterschrieben.
Also das bisschen was ist demnächst noch ein bisschen mehr. Aber das hat irgendwie der Chef vom Chef, dessen Chef noch nicht unterschrieben.
Die sind da immer äußerst langsam mit sowas.
Das ist Proto mal 14 bei uns. Achso, das muss man noch dabei sagen. Das ist mal 14. Also rein die Base-Geschichte ist das mal 14.
So, dann kommt noch dabei irgendwie so diese Standardgeschichten, diese Standard, was weiß ich, vermögenswirksamen Leistung,
wie viel sind das, 40 Euro oder so im Monat. So, und dann je nach Erfolg gibt es irgendwie noch ein bisschen mehr.
Und ich habe halt zusätzlich noch was zum Tarifvertrag. Also quasi so was, es steht bei mir im Arbeitsvertrag steht das als Bonus, was Schwachsinn ist,
weil es ist kein Bonus. Es ist ein Bonus, den ich jeden Monat kriege. Es ist im Prinzip ein Plus auf das, was im Tarifvertrag drin steht.
So, da kommt bei mir aber jetzt noch dabei, dass das nicht für 5 Tage, also das sind ja 5 Tage die Woche. Bei mir sind es ja nur 4 Tage die Woche.
Das heißt, man muss ja nochmal 20% abziehen. Also kommste da irgendwie auf 40k oder so rein vom Tarifvertrag oder? Nee, ja doch, ungefähr.
Also ungefähr 40k, wenn man es rein nach dem Tarifvertrag macht. Ja, so deswegen wollte ich meinen Chef mal fragen, ob das okay ist, wenn ich einfach den Rest auch noch liege.
Habe ich QuickMuffs falsch gemacht? Was habe ich falsch gemacht?
Wo habe ich falsch Muffs gemacht? Jetzt ihr Leute, das geht, also das ist wirklich nur, also wenn ihr in diesem Tarifvertrag seid, weil es jetzt schon wieder im Chatfeld gibt,
man kann da nicht mehr verdienen. Klar könnt ihr mehr verdienen. Das ist ja nur das Mindeste, was ihr kriegt, wenn euer Arbeitgeber in diesem Tarifvertrag drin ist.
In der Regel gibt es immer noch irgendwelche Bonusgeschichten. Es gibt meistens auch noch irgendwelche erfolgsabhängigen Sachen.
Also die wenigsten, die quasi einen Job haben, die dort in diesem Tarifvertrag sind, haben eins zu eins das, was im Tarifvertrag drin steht.
Ah, also es sind 50k im Jahr mit 4, okay kann auch sein. Ach, keine Ahnung, QuickMuffs, Alter.
Das glaube ich dir nicht, du jebaitest mich. Du hast, ich bin, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, du hast mir doch vor, glaube, keine Ahnung,
schon über einem Jahr in diesem Proxmox Streamer Dinger empfohlen für. Du hast doch schon zig VMs installiert, das ist doch jebait, oder?
So manche Sachen merke ich mir ja noch. Übrigens, als wir gerade mal hier bei Kohle waren, ah guck mal, er wurde erwischt.
Exposed. Ja, wo wir gerade bei Kohle waren, ich habe letztens eine Anfrage bekommen per Mail, ob ich nicht Werbung machen könnte, so eine Minute in einem Video zu einem Videoschnittprogramm.
Ja, okay, was habt ihr euch denn vorgestellt, kann ich machen, solange ich halt nicht irgendwie so persönliche Empfehlungen aussprechen muss,
weil ich benutze das Programm ja nicht, quasi vorstellen und die Features, die euch wichtig sind, kann ich erzählen.
Da habe ich halt einfach mal gesagt, hier Minute 800 Euro, ist denke ich durchaus auch gerechtfertigt bei den Aufrufen und was das sonst so kostet.
Und da meinten die jetzt, nö, ist ihnen zu teuer, sie wollen irgendwie nur ein Drittel davon bezahlen.
Nee, was letzte Preis habe ich keinen Bock.
Das sehe ich nicht ein. Auf der anderen Seite, also für 500 Euro würde ich das machen.
500 Euro, ich würde mich auf 500 Euro runterhandeln lassen, aber da gibt es wirklich nur 60 Sekunden abgelesene Features für.
Nein, nein, nicht für Premiere, für was anderes, für was, wo ich ehrlich gesagt noch nie was von gehört habe.
Ich habe mir die Seite von diesem Programm angeguckt, es sieht gar nicht so schlecht aus, aber, also ich will jetzt, was ich halt nicht mache,
ist Werbung und dann sagen, so nach dem Motto, ich bin riesenfähr, also ich mache, ich werde definitiv nie solche Beauty-Influencer haben,
so nach dem Motto, Leute, ich bin seit Jahren schon ein riesen Fan von diesem Programm und ich benutze es täglich,
jetzt könnt ihr, jetzt könnt ihr es euch auch hier runterladen und bekommen, dass sie schwach sind, das werde ich nicht machen.
Wenn ich was Gutes sage, wo ich dann sage, also auch persönlich empfehlen, das Empfehlen, dann ist das was, was ich auch benutzt haben muss.
Also die Hetzner-Geschichten, übrigens, by the way, Ausrufezeichen Hetzner, dann, die Hetzner-Geschichten kann ich ohne Bedenken,
so auch mit persönlicher Empfehlung versehen, weil die benutze ich ja selber schon lange.
Sponsored by Traffic, hey, weißt du was witzig ist, da wollte ich auch noch antworten, habe ich noch nicht gesagt,
die haben sich letztens nach dem Traffic mit einer ollen Sony Vegas Version, die ich mir mal gekauft habe und ja, ich habe mir die wirklich gekauft.
So, ich wurde letztens vom Traffic Community Managerin, ich wusste gar nicht, dass sie sowas haben,
von der Traffic Community Managerin angeschrieben nach dem Stream,
so, thanks for sharing your experience with our product, on stream oder irgendwie sowas und wenn ich mich online in so einem Formular eintrage,
schicken sie mir ein paar Traffic, wie nennt man das, so, so,
Giveaway-Dinger, so Aufkleber und Stifte und USB-Sticks wahrscheinlich sowas in der Richtung,
so Merchandise-Kram, ja, aber ich brauch den Kram nicht, ich hab schon MongoDB-Aufkleber auf meinem Notebook
und das nervt mich jedes Mal, dass ich den drauf geklebt hab, ich hab so viel Mist mittlerweile auf meinem Notebook packen,
dieses Viech als Kuscheltier, ich glaub sowas haben die nicht, ja, gibt's, aber ich glaub nicht, dass die scharf drauf sind, dass ich das schere,
aber was ich sagen kann ist, dass sowohl ich als auch Hetzner da zufrieden mit waren, wie viele Leute sich das angeguckt haben,
war echt nicht verkehrt, vor allem halt wie viele Leute dann auch nen Test-Account gemacht haben, war echt, war nicht verkehrt.
Swag, genau, ja genau, genau das mein ich. Doch letztens hat glaub ich irgendwer im Stream was geschrieben,
nee nicht von Traffic, wir hatten einen Maintainer von WLED da, wobei doch im Stream meinte auch einer von Traffic letztens Hello, irgendwie sowas.
Ich wollt den noch antworten, hab ich irgendwie voll verdrängt die letzte Woche.
Okay, also jetzt lass uns aber mal ein paar Programmier-Fonts angucken, also Hack ist beste, so was wollt man sonst noch ausprobieren?
Irgendjemand meinte, man kann ja auch sehen, wie man's installiert, seh ich jetzt hier ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Also Hack, Hack haben wir ausprobiert, Hack, Hack ist immer noch Pock.
Dann können wir noch, was haben die sonst noch drin, von denen ich ausprobieren wollte?
Ach, den hab ich früher auch mal kurz verwendet, der ist wirklich auch nice, Moment.
Das ist was anderes.
Das sieht doch nicht so aus normalerweise.
Ja so sieht der normalerweise aus.
Den hatte ich früher auch mal ne Weile, der ist auch cool.
Der ist auch cool.
Ich glaub, das ist den ihre Seite ist kaputt.
BitStreams, das ist der Base-Font von ganz vielen.
Also ganz viele dieser Monos Base-Fonts ist BitStream, Vera, Sans, Mono so die Basis.
KoreanU, das ist so der Microsoft Klassiker.
Ja, Vierer Code will ich auch noch ausprobieren.
Was haben wir da noch?
Cut-Wai-Kutive-Mono.
Die Seite ist ja voll broken.
Zack, vielleicht liegt es auch an meinem hier.
Ach, jetzt funktioniert das oder was?
Jetzt funktioniert der Anonymos Pro.
Stimmt, jetzt das weiß ich wieder.
Ich muss mal hier auf 100% gehen, jetzt machen wir hier die Size.
20 ist okay.
Also, den hab ich früher benutzt, ne Weile, genau.
Der war mir aber von der Lesbarkeit her, irgendwas hat mir da nicht gefallen dran.
So, dann hab ich jetzt ganz lang schon Hack.
Hack ist auch immer mit Abstand mein Lieblings-Font.
Was ich dann kurzzeitig noch mal hatte ist Source Code Pro.
Der Font ist überhaupt nicht so dünn.
Die Webseite ist fail.
Was ich dann eine Weile hatte ist Source Code Pro.
Der war mir aber zu breit.
Das sieht man jetzt hier nicht so schön.
Aber Source Code Pro ist mega, mega Pippo-White.
Ich glaube, ich muss den Kram doch installieren, dass man das richtig sieht.
Ich installiere es doch hier im Terminal.
Ansonsten gibt es hier die Seite.
Die Seite ist einfach broken.
Wir machen das jetzt von Hand.
Also, was müssen wir installieren?
Jetbrain, Mono.
Leute, ich mache mal kurz einen Snapshot.
Weil ich will die ganzen Fonts da gar nicht drauf haben.
Übrigens ein weiterer Punkt für Forever Workstation.
Man kann übrigens, VirtualBox kann das auch.
Ich finde es einfach nice, wie easy die ganzen Snapshot-Geschichten
über das Web-Interface über das GUI funktionieren.
Source Code Pro ist richtig thick.
Deswegen sah es in der Webseite nicht richtig aus.
Übrigens wisst ihr eigentlich, dass wir...
Hatten wir nicht einen Hack-Emote?
Doch, das hier.
Aber ich hatte doch auch einen Hack-Emote, wo man tippt.
Wo ist denn das Hack-Emote hin, wo man tippt?
Nein, nein, nicht das.
Wo der Keks tippt, hatten wir doch auch den Hack-Emote.
Guck mal, das hier.
Moment, ich zeige es euch.
Ja, hier ist der Max.
Oh, was steht da? Includes Paid Promotion.
Guck mal, da gibt es ein neues Bildchen für.
Guck mal, das da meine ich.
Wo ist denn der hin?
Ja, im Discord, aber ich dachte, wir hatten das alles genau.
Ich dachte, ich hatte das als Emote hier drin im Channel.
Die Musik ist zu Resident-Sleeper.
Ein bisschen Mario Kart gedudelt, geht immer.
Okay, ich glaube, es war keine gute Idee, den Snapshot zu löschen, Leute.
Der ist, glaube ich, huge.
Wieso hört sich die Stimme im Video anders an als im Stream?
Das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, weil ich mein Headset-Mikrofon hier verwende
und bei dem anderen mein größeres normales Mikrofon.
Und weil ich ein neues Geld und ein bisschen Filter hier drin habe,
dass es nicht rauscht und gedönnt.
Aber zum größten Teil ist es der Unterschied, Headset-Mikro zu normale Mikro.
Ich habe übrigens es auf der Arbeit mal geschafft.
Das ist aber auch schon ein paar Jahre her.
Da habe ich eine Linux-Kiste aufgebaut, ein Fileserver.
Ein Fileserver, das weiß ich noch, der war dafür da,
also glücklicherweise kein Fileserver, wo sich viel ändert,
sondern ein Fileserver für Downloads war das.
Linux-Kiste gemacht, Snapshot gemacht und irgendwann nach drei Jahren oder so
ruft mich einer von VMWare an und meint irgendwie,
Max, deine VM ist 4,7 Terabyte groß.
Da habe ich gesagt, hä? Wie? Kann auch gar nicht sein.
Bis ich da drauf gekommen bin, oh, die hat noch einen Snapshot.
Im Prinzip habe ich quasi jede Fileversion, die da drauf kopiert wurde,
gedifft in den Snapshot rein.
Da war es dann halt 4,7 Terabyte groß nach drei Jahren oder so.
Hätte ich nie gedacht, dass er so groß wird, aber ich meine, ist ja klar,
der muss sich ja immer den Diff dazu speichern.
Es ist aber auch ein bisschen fail, dass sie das nicht bemerkt haben.
200 Gigabyte, Lock, ach, das geht doch noch.
Daniel, null, 23 Monate.
Daniel, Dankeschön für den Sub, Massive Hyper Subscription.
Du bist auch so jemand, du bist schon ewig am Start,
du hast nie was im Chat, bist aber immer da.
Also, nice hier.
Guck mal, er hat aufgeräumt, wunderbar, hat funktioniert.
Du hast also versucht, das Internet runterzuladen.
Es sah so aus, ja, aber das Snapshot muss ich ja überlegen,
guck mal, nur mal so zu erklären, warum das so groß wird.
Wenn ich jetzt einen Snapshot mache hier,
dann muss der sich ja alles speichern,
was nach diesem Snapshot in der VM gemacht wurde,
damit er wieder zurück zu dem Snapshot kann.
Also, er speichert sich ja quasi einen Diff zum Snapshot.
So, und jetzt überlegt euch mal, das ist ein Download-Server gewesen,
und da wurde halt ab und zu mal eine neue Version von den Dateien hingelegt
oder auch eine neue Datei hingelegt und so was.
Und nach drei Jahren insgesamt, selbst wenn die Dateien,
die da draufliegen, vielleicht nur 40 Gigabyte sind,
aber innerhalb von drei Jahren und den Änderungen,
die du halt immer schreiben musst zu dem Snapshot,
ist halt das Ding irgendwann dann, keine Ahnung,
4,5, 4,7, was auch immer, Terabyte groß.
Aber der Snapshot sollte auch maximal so groß werden
wie der alte Zustand der VM.
Nein, das ist nicht so, ich kann es dir aber nicht erklären, warum.
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Snapshot-Size-Monitoring,
ja, sie haben es ja gemerkt, nach drei Jahren halt.
Okay, also installieren wir jetzt mal JetBrains,
TTF, JetBrains Mono, bam.
Warum soll ich Nerd-Fonts-Patched-Version nehmen?
Was ist denn Nerd-Fonts? Ist das das mit Emojis drinne?
Ah, Icon-Fonts, mit Icon-Fonts, oder?
Ah, yes, jetzt ist alles klar, oder?
Also ich finde, nach dem Diagramm ist es deutlich, deutlich logischer alles.
Ach, die Patchen, ach, jetzt verstehe ich, was die machen.
Jetzt verstehe ich, was die machen.
Die Patchen beliebte Fonts mit Icons aus den beliebten Icon-Fonts.
Also die nehmen quasi die Icons aus Material Design,
die nehmen die Icons aus Font Awesome, die nehmen was auch immer
und machen die Merchandise zusammen mit beliebten Mono-Space-Fonts,
sodass du quasi einen Font verwenden kannst,
der sowohl Icons hat, als auch gut aussieht.
Das ist eigentlich gerade nicht schlecht.
Haben die auch FFZ-Icons?
Nein, haben sie nicht, aber ich fände es geil, wenn sie es hätten.
Das klingt irgendwie nach einer schlechten Idee,
Icons von einer Font abhängig zu machen.
Naja, es gibt halt viele Software, die kann halt nur Fonts.
Also zum Beispiel hier oben die Icons.
I3 kann keine Bilder hier reinmalen.
Aber wenn du einen Font hast mit Bildern drin, dann funktioniert das.
Ja, und übrigens, das was du sagst, ist bei Emojis der Fall.
Das muss ich mal kurz in zwei Minuten...
Was? Wo? Link? Leute, Link, Overwatch 2 News Livestream.
YouTube, Overwatch.
Leute, ich kann aber jetzt keinen Overwatch-Stream gucken.
Ich wollte mit euch Programming-Fonts gucken.
Mein Headset ist am abkacken.
Nee, wir gucken keinen Overwatch-Stream.
Wir gucken keinen Overwatch-Stream.
Ihr seid bestimmt nicht da, um Overwatch-Stream zu gucken, oder?
Okay, Abstimmung, Abstimmung, Abstimmung, Abstimmung, Abstimmung.
Ja, nein.
Das wird eh nix. Overwatch 2 wird eh fail.
Leute, wenn ich das jetzt mache, verlier ich 50% meiner Zuschauer.
Ich hab ne andere Idee. Ich weiß, was wir machen.
Ich, ich weiß, was wir machen.
Wir werden einfach...
Guckt euch mal die Spammer. Guckt euch mal die Spammer an.
Wir werden einfach nicht den Overwatch-Stream gucken,
sondern wir werden einfach nachher oder nebenbei ab und zu mal ein bisschen reingucken
und drüber kecken, wie Overwatch 2 verkackt wird.
Kannste ja in nem kleinen Fenster laufen lassen.
Bild in Bild. Oh, jetzt wird's aber advanced, Alter.
Bild in Bild. Wie mach ich denn so was jetzt?
Ach, du Scheiße.
Wir müssen uns Bild in Bild auch nicht die komischen Blizzard.
Das ist übrigens der neue Jeff Kaplan hier.
Jeff Jeff ist ja weg.
Jeff Jeff.
Na, rechts unten in YouTube bringt mir nix.
Ich kann zwar Miniplayer machen, aber wenn ich in die Form wechsle, ist das ja weg.
Da fehlt ne Frau aus nicht diverse genug.
Wir machen einfach E3 in den Fenster.
Correct, wir machen einfach E3 in den Fenster.
Das ist ganz einfach. E3 einfach in den Fenster.
Und das pinnen wir an und fertig.
Easy. Oh ja, easy.
Moment, pass mal auf. E3.
Jetzt machen wir Hacker, man. Richtig krasse Hacker-Shit machen wir jetzt.
Pass mal auf.
Wie kann ich Videocontrolls anmachen?
Bild in Videocontrolls, geht das?
Moment, YouTube mit VLC.
Wir gucken es mit VLC.
Massive Big Brain jetzt.
Bam.
Huge. So und jetzt, und jetzt, und jetzt.
View.
Wie blende ich den Shit aus?
Was, Control-H?
Massive. So und jetzt muss ich Control-S glaube ich, ne Windows-S drücken zum Sticky machen.
Leute, bam.
Ist das nicht nice?
Wir haben es hingekriegt.
Richtig Hacker-Modus hier.
Sixhead.
Warum macht man nicht einen zweiten Teil für Overwatch?
Das weiß ich auch nicht.
Overwatch shift to five players per Team.
Äh, war das nicht schon immer so?
Nee, Quatsch. Sechs waren das immer. Sechs, ich bin Kacknoob.
Guck mal, Overwatch 2, fünf versus fünf anstatt sechs versus sechs.
Jaja, es waren sechs. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie ich da drauf komme, dass es fünf waren.
Ich finde es ja gut, dass sie hier so einen Untertitel machen, dann kann, fünf versus fünf.
Ich frage mich immer so, ob Blizzard sich das alles überlegt oder ob die, na egal.
Wir warten mal ab.
Ich finde das übrigens mit fünf versus fünf gar nicht schlecht, wenn du Feste-Comps spielen willst.
Also wenn du mit festen Leuten spielen willst, weil sechs Leute sind ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen viel.
Fünf kriegst du besser zusammen.
Aber mal gucken, mal gucken.
So, das wird jetzt eine wilde Mischung, Leute.
Wir programmieren, wir probieren Fonds aus und nebenbei lästern wir was Blizzard mit Overwatch 2 macht.
Oh, Big Brain Überleitung, habt ihr das gesehen?
Sieht das besser aus als das alte?
Nee, oder? Das sieht ein bisschen besser aus, also das sieht ein bisschen höher aufgelöst aus, alles, aber ansonsten.
Ansonsten sieht das ehrlich gesagt, das haben wir doch alle schon gesehen, das ist der neue Spielmodus, den kennen wir doch schon.
Ansonsten, das sieht alles ein bisschen nach minimal mehr Polygonen aus und ein bisschen kantiger, aber ansonsten.
Wie viel RAM hast du eigentlich? 32G.
Ja.
So, jetzt stellen wir nebenbei mal die Font um.
Kann ich überhaupt den Font vom Terminal ändern?
Während ich's offen hab oder muss ich das neu starten?
Font.
Äh.
Wie hieß das Ding? JetBrains?
Ha, das geht nicht.
Okay, das ist Fail.
Das sackt.
Ich hab VLC, nämlich über das Terminal laufen.
Ja, dann mach ich das halt in VS Code, ne?
Dann mach ich das halt in VS Code, geht auch.
Settings.
Äh, wie muss ich das jetzt nennen?
JetBrains Mono? So?
W-wie heißt denn der Font?
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht der Font.
Ähm.
Leute, ich brauch mal einen anderen Editor, wo ich was aus...
Ah, ja, ja, ja, FC List, hast recht.
Ich, ich mach das mal wieder.
Okay.
Ich, ich mach das mal hier drin.
Da hab ich n' scheiß Gui.
Ne, ich glaub, im Jason vervollständigt sich das nicht.
Okay.
Ähm, Font.
JetBrains Mono.
Alter, das ist schon starr...
Äh, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Hier.
JetBrains Mono.
Safe.
Hm.
D-das sieht höher aus, alles.
Guck mal, das sieht...
Das, die, irgendwie sieht, sieht die...
Das sieht, das, das sieht nach, das sieht nach oben gestreckt aus,
alles gegen, äh, wenn man das mal mit Hack vergleicht.
Das ist ja, ist ja klar, das ist mit Sicherheit Absicht.
JetBrains Mono hab ich doch richtig geschrieben.
Vielleicht muss man via Scout einfach neu starten?
Ist schon, ist okay, ist okay, ja.
W-w-w-was da?
Äh, äh.
Na, jetzt hat er's gecheckt.
Das ist auf jeden Fall höher.
Das ist, also, das ist aber gut sichtbar, muss man sagen.
Das ist schon in Ordnung.
Das müssen wir uns das Side-by-Side mal angucken.
Ähm, aber ich glaub, ich kann, ich kann die Dinger nicht Side-by-Side aufmachen, ne?
Was ist das jetzt Side-by-Side auf?
Gehwim, easy.
Screenshot?
Ja, ne.
Screenshot.
Hab ich noch was zum Screenshotten dabei?
Okay, Screenshot, bam.
Open.
So, Screenshot.
Jetzt haben wir den Screenshotten.
Jetzt gehen wir mal zurück.
Hack.
So, das ist der, das ist...
Ob ich das so fett?
Also, das ist der normale Font, den ich hab, und das ist der andere.
Also, man muss sagen, es ist jetzt nicht so nen Riesenunterschied.
Ich würd fast sagen...
Also, der ist nen Ticken breiter, aber...
Ich würd, ich würd fast sagen, die Base, die Base der beiden Fonts ist die gleiche.
Also, ich würd sagen, Hack und JetBrains Mona hat die gleiche Font-Base, auf jeden Fall.
Ne, guckt euch das S an, das ist schon ein Unterschied.
Das S ist geschwungener als das S.
Hier, ne?
Guckt, das S hier.
Und das hier ist runder geschwungener, und das ist ein bisschen länglicher, das S.
Ja, okay.
Es ist auf jeden Fall kein großer Unterschied.
Gucken, das C ist hier auch runder, runder, und hier ist...
Ja, okay.
Also, ich könnte mir vorstellen, man bekommt, bekommt man damit irgendwie mehr Zeichen oder
so in der Zeile, weil das ein bisschen, ein bisschen enger ist.
Also, ich mein, das hier ist nen Ticken enger als das.
Hm.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein nicer Font.
Also, da würd ich mich nicht schämen für, ja.
Das I, Main.
Ja, es ist...
Ja, okay, das ist eher so dieses, dieses, dieses Times New Roman I, und das ist hier
halt so ein Schreibschrift I.
Stimmt, wir machen mal hier L, L, I, I, O, O, O.
Muss man mal vergleichen.
Was, was sagt uns eigentlich da oben jetzt gerade Overwatch, äh, da Overwatch stellt?
Was sagt der uns jetzt hier gerade?
Da Overwatch stellt, sagt er uns, ich versteh nix?
Dass er, er reinhartet vor sich hin?
Alter, wer ist Quirky Turtle?
No Aim, No Brain, Winston, Main, Keck, Wade.
Oh nee, Moment, ist das 2CP?
Nee, nee, was für ein Spielmodus ist das, Leute?
Keck, Wade, wartet mal.
Was zum?
Nee.
Was für ein Spielmodus ist das?
Capture?
Assault?
Ist das Capture Point oder?
Das ist Assault, ne?
Capture.
Also das ist Assault, das erste einnehmen und dann spawnt der Payload?
Ja, ja, ja.
2CP kommt ja weg, zum Glück.
2CP ist der schlimmste Spielmodus aller Zeiten gewesen.
Naja.
Es ist halt mit 5 Spielern jetzt, ne?
Das ist eine coole Anzeige, dass man den Mercy Strahl drauf hat.
Man sieht jetzt ein bisschen besser, wer was macht im Casting Overlay, das ist schon mal
nicht verkehrt.
Ach, vielleicht ist das alles nur Caster Overlay.
Ja, der Genji hittet aber gut.
Ich glaube, wir müssen das Commentary von dem Dude nicht hören, oder?
Was sind das überhaupt für Leute?
Wer ist Robot Angel?
Und Köln must task.
Übrigens, ein Problem hat man in Overwatch immer noch.
Das haben die nach wie vor nicht hinbekommen.
Casual Zuschauer, die selbst, sagen wir mal, nicht wirklich viel Overwatch spielen, du
verstehst nicht, was passiert.
Das ist nach wie vor immer noch ein riesen Problem, auch bei Competitive Overwatch.
Du verstehst nicht, was passiert.
Das checkt keiner.
Und selbst wenn du das spielst, muss man, huge ult, massive ult, und selbst wenn du
das spielst, du blickst nicht durch.
Ich glaube, Overwatch Spectating ist so eines der schwierigsten Sachen, so eines der schwierigsten
Sachen überhaupt, und das funktioniert nach wie vor immer noch nicht.
Huge Winston Stels, Alter.
Ja, spring mal schön in die Shotguns rein, ohne Support.
Wunderbar.
Ich bin voll verwirrt.
Ich denke immer, blau ist das eigene Team, aber das ist ja Overwatch Spectator, Overwatch
Spectator.
Oh.
What the?
Was war das?
Momokas.
Jetzt habe ich den Massive Shatter Block gar nicht gesehen.
Okay, das sind Entwickler, wahrscheinlich, die da spielen.
Okay, lass uns mal schnell die Combs angucken.
Was haben die am Start?
Genji, Winston, was ist das, Pharah, Pharah, Genji, Winston, Zenyatta, Mercy, Doppel, Doppel,
Support, Single, Tank.
Äh gut, das sind aber nur 5.
Zenyatta, Ana, Axe.
Also die halten aber anscheinend an Doppel Support fest, also anscheinend ist jetzt gewollt
von Blizzard Single, Tank.
Das mit Single, Tank funktioniert.
Ich stelle mir das gerade für sowas wie Winston und so ziemlich schwierig vor als komplett
Solo Tank, wenn du keine, du hast ja keine Chance auf irgendwelche Zarya Bubbles oder
auf irgendwas.
Das stelle ich mir eher nach RIP vor.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine neue Map, glaube ich zumindest.
Wie gesagt, ich habe 2 Jahre oder so nicht mehr gespielt, aber ich glaube, das ist eine
neue Map.
Wäre auch blöd, wenn die nicht eine neue Map zeigen würden.
Ja, okay, ansonsten passiert da jetzt nicht allzu viel.
5 DPS, naja, wenn die das wieder so machen, wie aktuell in Rank, dann kannst du nicht
5 DPS spielen.
Während der Beta war das ja witzig, wo du noch die, oder auch kurz nach Release, wo
du noch die Helden doppelt picken konntest.
Okay, das war mal eine schöne Zen-Ult, ein bisschen spät vielleicht, aber.
Hat Felix mal der Ass gesaved.
Was genau sich jetzt geändert hat, es sind nur noch 5 Leute im Team.
Die Mario Kart Musik ist auch neu.
Also ich weiß noch, in der Beta doppelt Winston, doppelt Reaper und Support weiß ich gar nicht
mehr.
Das war auf jeden Fall total pepega.
Reinhard hat kein Helm mehr auf auf dem Bild.
Also ich glaube, ich glaube, wenn man feste Teams machen will, ist es mit 5 Spielern deutlich
besser als mit 6, weil du einfach 5 Spieler viel einfacher findest als 6.
So banal sich das anhört, ja.
Ob es jetzt fürs Gameplay besser ist, kommt drauf an.
Also das funktioniert auf jeden Fall auch.
Wobei ich halt, frage ich mich, also ich frage mich halt, wie gut man sowas wie Solo
ohne jegliche Sachen dabei spielen kann.
Naja, egal.
0-3, easy, wahrscheinlich schon Vorfeld aufgezeichnet alles.
Damit nehmen die ja Pro-Teams auseinander, weil man einen Main-Spieler streichelt.
Das stimmt, da habe ich ja doch überhaupt nicht dran gedacht, du hast ja recht.
Das ist eigentlich rübelster Sucker-Move von Blizzard.
Aber gut, bei Blizzard muss man sich ja da keine Gedanken zu machen.
Die haben ja auch bei Heroes of the Storm von heute auf morgen gesagt, by the way, wir
machen dicht, falls die Pro-Teams noch leben.
Es gibt ja eigentlich gar keine Pro-Teams mehr, oder?
Also ich meine, es gibt im Prinzip Overwatch League und sonst gibt es nichts.
Also ja, ich weiß, dass es prinzipiell Contenders gibt, aber naja.
Es gibt Contenders auf dem Papier, sagen wir mal so, ja.
Contenders wurde ja auch nie von Blizzard groß beworben.
Also das war schon fail.
Generell ist der ganze, sorry Leute, dass ich jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen in den Overwatch-Rant verfalle.
Eigentlich wollten wir uns Schriftart angucken.
Aber, ähm, also die haben das schon echt verkackt.
Die haben das schon richtig verkackt.
Jedes andere E-Sport-Game hat, also lebt davon, dass es quasi S-Tier gibt, Tier 1, 2, 3, sagen wir mal so, ja.
Oder wie auch immer man die Tiers nennen mag.
Overwatch hat das nicht.
Overwatch hat S-Tier, die sich zum größten Teil aus irgendwelchen Koreanern mittlerweile rekrutieren,
die selbst keinen Bock mehr auf das Game haben, aber halt Geld dafür bekommen.
Und Tier 1, 2, 3 existiert in Overwatch nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie Blizzard der Meinung war, dass das in irgendeiner Art und Weise funktionieren kann.
Am Anfang, am Anfang gab es ja noch einen riesen Hype, da wo Blizzard noch nicht alles dicht gemacht hat mit Overwatch League.
Du hattest deine Weekly-Cups und sonstige Geschichten.
Aber selbst das hat Blizzard damals auch nicht richtig gefördert.
Also der Hype war am Anfang auf jeden Fall da.
Ich meine sogar ich habe Competitive Overwatch gespielt.
Ich meine ich war damals auch schon 33.
No Aim, No Pray, Name nicht Winston-Main, Lucio-Main, Alter.
Lucio-Main.
Aber das war schon cool, aber die haben es einfach komplett verkackt.
Die haben beispielsweise auch nie beworben, wenn irgendwelche Games waren.
Überlegt euch, wie lange hat es gedauert, bis eben Launcher da drinnen war, wenn es großartige Matches gab.
Also größere Matches.
Und spätestens mit dem Wechsel von Twitch auf YouTube hat es kein Mensch mehr geguckt.
Die Zuschauerzahlen von Competitive Overwatch sind sonst wo.
Die sind komplett am Arsch.
Ich meine, die Leute gucken mehr Hearthstone.
Gut, Hearthstone ist ja auch cool zuzugucken.
Random, RNG-Stone.
Ace, hast du nicht mal sogar oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Hast du nicht mal sogar für Deutschland beim World Cup teilgenommen oder wolltest teilnehmen?
Oder irgendwas in der Richtung, kann das sein?
Oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander?
War das nicht der World Cup, wo Blizzard gesagt hat, sie bezahlen nichts mehr?
Wo die gesagt haben, wir machen einen World Cup, aber die Leute müssen alles selbst bezahlen?
Wo ich mir auch gedacht habe, Alter, Blizzard, please.
Naja.
Okay.
So.
Also, ich würde sagen, wir gucken uns doch mal kurz die Schrift nach weiter an.
Meinung zu TSGO, ja.
Ich war übelst huge TSGO, also Zugucken-Fan.
Ich war noch sogar mal live hier auf so einem Major zu meiner TSGO-Hype-Zeit.
Richtig nice, ja.
Ich gucke mir ab und zu immer noch ein paar Matches an.
Ich war ja immer irgendwie so ein bisschen NiP-Fan, auch wenn sie schon gesagt haben.
So, also wir müssen noch mal kurz die Sachen hier vergleichen.
Mal kurz Screenshot.
Ja, von dem da.
Und jetzt stellen wir hier noch mal um auf JetBrains Mono.
Ja, man hat den Unterschied gesehen gerade, seht ihr?
Ja, und jetzt vergleichen wir das mal.
Okay, also die haben den Punkt bei dem O.
Und die Null ist eckiger.
Das easy, klar.
Ja, also ich muss sagen, also ich bin der Meinung, der Fond, worauf die beide basieren, ist der gleiche.
Das sieht schon verdammt ähnlich aus.
Aber JetBrains Mono ist tatsächlich, so wie eindeutig die Sachen aussehen, finde ich fast klarer.
Haben die sowas hier, oder wie schaltet man das überhaupt ein?
Scatter.
Nice Headshot.
Ich glaube, das Showcase von dem Match ist, die wollen zeigen, wie jeder Held wird gepickt, so nach dem Motto.
Muss Fond, okay, wie macht man das hier?
Die gar, äh, was, True?
Okay, okay, pass auf.
Ne, das gefällt mir nicht.
Mag das nicht, ich bin da wirklich kein Fan von.
Mach mal gleich, gleich, gleich.
War da.
Ne, ich, ich kann mich damit nicht anfreuen.
Gibt's, jemand, hat jemand von euch?
Hat das jemand von euch an?
Also benutzt das jemand täglich?
Ich hab's schon mal probiert, aber ich komm damit, ich mag's nicht.
Ich mag's nicht.
Ich hab mich, glaube ich, so dran gewöhnt, dass sowas hier eben so aussieht und nicht so.
Du hast den Turret an, okay.
Also ich mag's nicht.
Was, was, was, was haben die noch für, für Zeichen, sowas hier?
Aha.
Ah ne, sowas haben wir nicht, okay.
Äh, was haben wir, was gibt's noch für, für, für.
Oh, oh, jetzt wird's advanced.
Mach mal ein Bin Bash oben im Skript oben, ich muss es ja nicht, ich muss es ja nicht oben machen.
Kann ich irgendwo, irgendwo machen?
Ah, guck mal, das macht er tatsächlich schräg, naja.
Aber ich bin da kein Fan von.
Und, und, ja genau, und, und.
Ah, okay, das sieht, sieht genauso aus.
Ich bin, ich bin da, ich kann mich damit nicht anfreuen, ich bin da einfach kein, kein Fan von.
Wie ist denn sowas hier, genau.
Ah, guck mal, das macht er auch zusammen.
Was gibt's noch für abgedrehte JavaScript Operators?
Wow, what the.
Cursed.
Was gibt's denn da noch, drei Punkte?
Du fährst ehrlich gesagt nichts mal ein.
Ach hier.
Wait a minute.
Ah.
Okay, das ist cool, das ist da.
What?
Was ist denn das für einen fucking Operator?
Was soll denn tilde tilde Pfeil sein?
Was ist denn tilde tilde Pfeil?
Wo verwendet man das denn?
F sharp?
Haskell?
Keine Ahnung.
Okay, ich werd auf jeden Fall damit nicht mal haben.
Ich, ich mag das nicht.
False.
Ja, mir ist das so viel, viel lieber, Leute, viel lieber.
Hat Heck, hat Heck sowas auch?
Ich glaube, Heck hat sowas nicht.
Font.
Nee, Heck hat sowas nicht.
Bis zu vier Hashtags hintereinander.
Okay, das ist wirklich Big Brain.
Gut, aber nee, also ich bin da wirklich kein Fan von.
Ich mag das einfach nicht.
Okay, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich hätte es zwar nicht gedacht,
aber mir gefällt, so jetzt, ich müsste es noch mal ein bisschen ausbilden.
Mir gefällt, mir gefallen die doppeldeutigen Buchst, also die Sachen,
die man falsch interpretieren könnte, also sowas wie Null und O und so,
die finde ich tatsächlich und auch vor allem das I, das muss ich sagen,
das gefällt mir in dem Font besser als in Heck.
Oh, sagen hätte ich nicht gedacht, aber nice auf jeden Fall, sehr nice.
So, nächster Font, was probieren wir jetzt aus?
Was jetzt? VLC, please. VLC, was soll das?
Hör auf.
Ach guck mal, das ist der neue Spielmodus, der jetzt kommt.
So, also das haben wir jetzt ausprobiert.
Nice, so und jetzt probieren wir mal den neuen Microsoft,
jetzt probieren wir mal den neuen Microsoft-Font aus.
Cascadia ist das neue Microsoft-Ding, oder?
Was war vorher noch mal? Vierer Code machen wir danach.
Davor war Lucida Console, und dann war Cascadia.
Cascadia-Code ist jetzt das neue.
Okay.
Okay, Code, also was müssen wir jetzt machen?
FC, List, Crab, Cascadia, Cascadia-Mono brauchen wir.
Cascadia-Mono, dann wird es für Microsoft-ifiziert.
Das funktioniert, glaube ich, nur mit Windows-Font-Rendering.
Das sieht nicht gut aus.
Ich glaube, das funktioniert nur mit Windows-Font-Rendering, guck mal.
Hat man Cascadia-Code standardmäßig drauf?
Wir machen das jetzt mal testweise hier, guck mal.
.cs, wir kopieren das gleich hier rein.
So, das ist Hack, das ist Hack unter Windows.
Hack unter Windows ist, wie ihr seht, auch deutlich fetter.
Font, ah nee, Setting.
Ach, Konsolas ist das, Cascadia.
Das sieht ja noch hässlicher aus.
Oder ist das der Fallback-Font unter Windows?
Nee, das ist der Fallback-Font unter Windows.
Nee, das ist ja Müll.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das ist ja nix.
Das interessiert, das mag ich nicht.
Cascadia-Code, wie sollte es denn sonst aussehen?
Wie sollte es denn eigentlich aussehen?
Ah, schön, eine Font-Seite ohne bisschen Beispiele.
Ich mein, so kann es sich noch kein Mensch vorstellen.
Ja, es ist anscheinend normal, dass es so fett ist.
Nee, das mag ich nicht.
Okay, was wollen wir als Vierer-Code?
Bam, yes.
Okay, Code Restart.
Das ist Hanamura, nee, das ist Fake-Hanamura im Schnee.
Die hatten auch keinen Bock, neue Sachen zu bauen für Overwatch 2, oder?
Na doch, doch, ist schon komplett neu.
So, also, dann schalten wir das mal ein.
Jetzt.
Äh, Vierer, Vierer, Vierer, Vierer-Regular.
Oder einfach nur so.
Zack.
Äh.
Äh, warum checkt er das nicht?
Was hab ich falsch gemacht?
Ich muss das klein schreiben, oder?
Hä.
Äh, was hab ich falsch gemacht?
Ah, Vierer-Code, Leer-Zeichen.
Lul, weh.
Das ist ja auch so breit.
Warum ist denn das alles so breit?
Ey, mein, guck mal.
Da.
Wir sind hier bei dem, wir sind hier am Ende von dem I.
Da sind wir am Anfang davon.
Das ist viel breiter.
Das ist voll, voll Sixhead-Fonds.
Es ist aber auf jeden Fall ein bisschen dünner.
Nehmen wir mal Medium.
Das ist jetzt zu, zu fett.
Hm.
Ich mein, wer, wer dicke, dicke Schrift mag, für den ist das wahrscheinlich nicht verkehrt.
So, gucken wir uns das Ganze mal an hier mit True.
Ja, hier hast du die, wie hast du das, wie hast du das, wie hast du das, wie hast du das, wie hast du das, wie hast du das?
Ja, hier hast du die, wie hast du das, wie hast du das, wie hast du das, wie hast du das?
Die Retina-Variante mag ich aber am liebsten.
Welche ist das davon?
Ach hier.
The Big Brain 80K Displays.
Oh ja, tatsächlich.
Die gefällt mir auch.
dicker als das andere, aber nicht ganz so fett.
Ja.
Also, sag mal mal, ich kann verstehen, wenn das jemand verwendet.
Hack gefällt mir da immer noch besser.
Ich mein, der Vorteil, muss man halt auch mal sagen,
ähm, von so'n bisschen dickeren Fonts ist, die fransen nicht so aus, ja?
Also hack, grad auf meinem Display, ich hab ja ein relativ, ein relativ großes Display für 1080p.
Ich mein, ich hab ne, was sind das überhaupt, äh,
24, 25 Zoll, mit 1080p, da, da siehst du die Pixel schon ein bisschen.
Und so, umso dicker die Fonts sind, also die fransen halt nicht so aus.
Das seht ihr jetzt nicht, weil wahrscheinlich das bei euch ganz anders aussieht.
Zock, dankeschön für das.
Und, und sieht tatsächlich komisch aus, ja?
Guck mal mal, wie und, und ohne legatores aussieht.
Äh, auch kacke.
Ne, das und und gefällt mir auch gar nicht.
Die null find ich gut, ja?
Die null find ich gut, die hat was.
Aber insgesamt, boah, nicht so.
So, jetzt kommt was für die Apple, jetzt kommt was, jetzt kommt was für die Apple, für die Apple-Fans.
Jetzt kommt was für die Apple-Fans, und zwar Meslo.
Das hab ich ne ganze Weile verwendet.
Der ist auch nice.
Zeig noch mal kleines L, hier.
Äh, ach so, kleines L hab ich gehabt.
Ja, das ist okay, das ist in Ordnung, kann man so lassen.
Kann man, kann man gut unterscheiden.
Die Schriftart findest du super, kostet aber 200 Dollar.
Ob ich, ob ich bei so viel verfügbaren Schriftern wirklich 200 Dollar für ne Schriftart ausgeben will.
Die wär mir ein bisschen zu, zu, zu fancy, glaub ich.
Auch gerade, gerade hier unten mit dem, mit dem E und so.
Es sieht ein bisschen aus, sieht ein bisschen aus wie die, wie diese alte Apple-Schriftart.
Ähm, wie hießen die alte Apple, Mono Space font, wie hießen die alte Apple-Schriftart?
Monaco, Monaco.
Es hat ein bisschen was davon.
Es hat ein bisschen was von, von diesem alten Apple-Font.
Finde ich jetzt, aber das wär mir zu fancy.
Die geschweiften Klammern sehen aus wie ein Bogen.
Massive, Massive Robin Hood-Stells.
Ja, aber das ist echt eine super subjektive Geschichte, ne.
So, jetzt probier mal Measlow aus.
Das ist wirklich, probier mal IBM Plexmono, machen wir.
Aber Measlow ist wirklich cool, den mag ich, den mag ich.
Oh ja.
Ach du Scheiße, das da sind wie die Nullen und so aussehen sollen.
Ich weiß aber nicht für was, was steht ehrlich gesagt.
Ach du Scheiße.
Das ist Dotted Zero, Dotted Zero, ähm, ich hab keine Ahnung.
das ist dort 0 dort 0 ich habe keine ahnung
ja aber der ist cool der fand oder das ist das ist das ist der apple das standard apple
fand das standard apple fand den mag ich also der ist nice der sieht clean aus der
ist wirklich clean den habe ich auch eine ganze weile verwendet
aber ich muss halt sagen hack hack immer noch beste wie findet ihr den es ist halt standard
apple jetzt ist der apple dass der apple standard fand wenn für was steht in der kram meslo dz lg
was ist denn was dot tz
woher weiß ich denn was was ist dort 0 was was ist denn was also gibt es irgendwo
eine ordentliche erklärung zu keine ahnung kein schimmer aber da ist auf jeden fall
nice den habe ich auch eine ganze zeit verwendet was hältst du vom neuen discord
von ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen was machen die da aber eigentlich die spiel
in neuen spielmodus mich nicht so
ok was soll als nächstes ibm plex mono da bin ich mal gespannt drauf habe ich noch 0
gesehen oder probiert plex mono das ist das ist auf erwacht der auf erwacht 2 stream ist
dass der gerade läuft ja ich habe gehofft man sieht da vielleicht ein bisschen ein bisschen
spannendes zeug aber ich verstehe noch nicht genau warum es auf erwacht 2 sein muss wenn
ich ehrlich bin warum macht man nicht einfach auf erwacht mit einer single player xx patch
season auf erwacht season 2 oder auf erwacht season 5 ich verstehe ich verstehe nicht bis
heute nicht warum die mit auf erwacht nicht mehr gemacht haben ich meine die haben auf
erwacht ist jetzt was fünf jahre alt oder so und die haben paar maps und paar helden
released ansonsten nichts das kannst du nicht machen fortnight ich wüsste ich bin kein
battle royale ne es ist nicht stonks es ist das gegenteil von stonks ich bin kein battle
royale fan also entsprechend liegt mir jetzt nichts daran irgendwie fortnight übelst zu
hypen aber fortnight hat gezeigt wie es funktioniert die haben so viel updates und content gebracht
dass die leute permanent hype sind waren auf das game die müssen content bringen du kannst
doch nicht ein game rausbringen und und innerhalb von fünf jahren zwei maps und und drei chars
und auch dem motto das funktioniert nicht oder was nach plex muss ich suchen über drei über
erstmal ein font installiert und und ein font installiert und erstmal hundert hundert zwölf
varianten von bekommen ist kein problem was was davon soll ich nehmen ich nehme jetzt
einfach ibm plex ohne da was dafür einzugeben blutet font leute plot plotet plotet font
font so ibm plex mono so sieht das standardmäßig also aus das sieht aus wie eine host konsole
ein bisschen dünn ein bisschen sehr dünn die klammern sind pence champ ich meine man
kann sie gut erkennen das muss man sagen aber die klammern klammern sind ok wir haben wir
haben das richtige extra light medium medium kann ich auch medium sagen hier medium das
ist zu fett das ist zu fett extra light 200
vielleicht so schreiben zu durfte sein zu schreiben hier das ist zu zu dünn einfach
nur leit haben wir jetzt regular regular ok das ist das ist die fault das ist das ist
das standard anscheinend von dem font danach danach gibt es dann bloß noch medium ja ich
weiß nicht was sagt ihr chat warum ist da aufwärts in der ecke weil grad der aufwärts
zwei livestream läuft ich habe gedacht es gibt da irgendwas spannendes bei zu sehen
nee also ich finde es nicht so geil
ja also wenn man schon den csv hat ich bin aber wahrlich kein xl fan aber wenn die sachen
schon in csv hatten man einfach nur ein graf brau ist wahrscheinlich ganz ganz schick
ich sag dir mal was du noch machen könntest wenn schicker wenn schicker werden soll beziehungsweise
wenn du regelmäßig updates machen willst also ich würde dir sowas hier empfehlen gucken
wir zum beispiel mal mein dashboard an für die heizung hier kommen werte von meiner heizung
rein aus dem keller allerdings nicht als csv sowas ist natürlich cool weil da kannst du
hier rein zoomen also wenn du es interaktiv machen willst ist natürlich poggers und sieht
schick aus dann musst du aber irgendwie dann csv in was reinbekommen was grafana versteht
ich habe keine ahnung ob grafana csv kann ok ich habe nichts gesagt grafana kann csv
ja dann ist ja noch noch einfacher wtf seit wann kann denn grafana csv
moment es ist das ist das ist ein zusätzliches guitar projekt 16 sterne naja aber man kann
zwar probieren wenn man es direkt mit csv haben will ansonsten wenn es sich als öfters
aktualisiert würde ich sagen kannst du deine daten auch in irgendeine influx db oder sonst
was reinschreiben dann wäre es natürlich mit grafana besonders cool
ja das ist auch so ein punkt wo man halt sieht epic games zeigt im endeffekt wie es geht
du brauchst content am fließband hype content am fließband ich meine die haben ja an collaborations
nix ausgelassen von batman bis infinity war ne ne ne quatsch wie hieß es endgame und infinite
war infinity war wie hieß der scheiß noch einmal das war für zeugs die haben ja alles
alles gefiltert was irgendwie geht probieren victor mono mache ich mache ich
den habe ich immer gerne geguckt in der overwatch league habe vergessen wie er heißt das der
australische casta ist nicht miss x es ist der typ noch mal egal vergessen
es ist es ist über uber uber ist es genau so victor mono da bin ich jetzt ja mal gespannt
victor mono pick tor mono ok anscheinend einfach nur so gut ist regular
victor mono monka der ist busy dünn ok da muss ja da muss was größeres nehmen moment
moment das ist medium medium medium was haben wir zur auswahl medium light es gibt kein
regular deswegen nimmt der leit doch regular medium medium
bolt ist jetzt bescheuern was mache ich denn falsch
victor mono medium das ist auch eine dicke oder light
light kannst du gar nicht erkennen bolt kann man das einfach so machen
ok ich weiß nicht wer das empfohlen hat eben aber was muss ich einstellen dass es funktioniert
ok extra light ok moment ich muss jetzt wissen was extra light aussieht in dem font alles
klar alles klar jetzt erkennt sie jetzt erkennt sie so vorne changes zu tank roll ja tanks
können jetzt anscheinend damage machen habe ich da aus dem augenwinkel gesehen also alle
anscheinend denn die font s störungen sieht echt so aus wie kriege ich das jetzt ein
bisschen fetter ok es gibt tank changes kommt mal hier der hamster macht jetzt richtig damage
ultra bolt gibt es ultra bolt also wir haben ok wir haben medium medium light ok vielleicht
hat visual studio auch damit probleme ich macht es noch mal über rider stelle ich das
noch mal ein ja ja ist gut ok anscheinend kein reinheit jetzt auch damage machen und
heute ich sage euch wie es ist die verkacken auf watch 2 wie sagt man cs safe call ok die
klammern sehen wirklich so kacke aus es ist mir zu dünn und die klammern sehen kacke
aus also was wollten wir jetzt ausprobieren victor mono hier es ist so dünn glaube ich
glaube das ist so nee das ist mir zu dünn also viel vielleicht kommt das mit dem windows
font rendering besser raus gibt auch hektor nee das brauche ich nicht das ist so bisschen
ein bisschen sehr dünn an sich finde ich den font insofern ganz cool dass es wohl relativ
viel in einer zeile unterbringt also dass es ein bisschen minimal gestaucht wirkt aber
dementsprechend auch die zeile und die länge recht gut ausgenutzt wird aber das ist doch
schon ganz schön ganz schön small mini cup nee das ist mir glaubt zu was ist denn mono
ied mono ied font ttf mono ied mono ied gibts auch noch was meint was will der was will
er da alles installieren lip spiral portrays woff für den fucking font der kompilierten
font sehe ich das richtig ich will keinen font kompilieren bloatet alles bloatet ja was
kann man sonst noch ausprobieren also robotung muss man nicht ausprobieren das ist auch skott
pro haben wir uns auch schon angeguckt terminus alter leute terminus das habe ich installiert
das jetzt wirds pains champ nee hab ich nicht installiert jetzt jetzt jetzt wirds pains
champ leute terminus das ist richtig richtig oldschool font terminus font pass mal auf
pass mal auf terminus was mache ich falsch kann das sein dass das ein font ist ach das
kann visual studio gar nicht den font nee aber was habe ich denn jetzt installiert ah
das ist der falsche font ok ok haben wir hier terminus ttf was ist ein otb font irgendein
bitmap font out of date font egal out of date font ich will immer out of date fonts installieren
achtung terminus ja immer noch nicht erkannt wo ist das problem warum ach man muss terminus
ttf ok das ist natürlich bescheuerte benahmung da kommt auch keiner drauf das ist terminus
ich meine man erkennt die sachen gut auseinanderhalten das ist das ist der richtige oldschool hacker
man font oh sick kriegen wir das hin terminus terminus bold
medium medium ist das medium standard medium er erkennt mir die hälfte kein bock ok das
wird zu zu unhackermann ich aber terminus ist der oldschool hacker font fantast was
für ein ding ok mache ich mache ich fand das kuh fand das wie sprich man es fand fand
fand das dick zwei bärm jawoll mache ich wow what the fuck ich wollte jetzt aufhauen
ich gar nicht so fett man fand fand das kuh fand das kuh fand fand das kuh sans mono
regula ok code schauen wir mal settings bam das ist gut der gefällt mir ganz gut er erinnert
mich auch ein bisschen an den alten apple default font der ist ein bisschen verspielter an der
stelle der ist ein bisschen schnörkeliger was das k warum ist das k so schlecht ok das
k ist ernsthaft geschmackssache das k ist wirklich gewöhnungsbedürftig ja richtig monark s macht
das weg ich finde gar nicht schlecht ich finde aber das k ist wirklich das k macht es macht
es ein bisschen kaputt der rest finde ich ganz nice die klammern finde ich auch mal angenehm
ligatores hat er machen wir true patrick du bist jetzt der 580 glaube ich der den witz
mit comics anspringen ich finde gar nicht schlecht wo ich ehrlich sage ich kann verstehen
wenn man den font verwendet mir persönlich gefällt das k überhaupt nicht ja es ist
wirklich es ist wirklich sehr platz platz sparen also ziemlich ziemlich bisschen gestaucht
ja oh leute ich habe gerade auf die uhr geguckt wtf ich habe sie überhaupt nicht mitbekommen
es ist boomer time es ist boomer time leute sudo font moment was ist das sudo font das
interessiert mich jetzt auch sudo font was ist was warum heißt denn font sudo ttf sudo
das muss ich jetzt noch ausprobieren das hat so einen merkwürdige namen ok moment moment
sehe ich das richtig wir installieren gerade die schrift art die schrift wir installieren
die schrift in version 0.51 alles klar fc sudo ok der kramer ist wirklich sudo also sudo
sudo medium gibt es aber ich schreibe da einfach nur sudo rein und guck mal wie es aussieht
boah das ist ja mikroskopisch alter ok also die die legen wert drauf die komplette zeilenhöhe
komplett auszunutzen da wird da wird da wird jede zeile komplett ausgereizt aber an sich
auch relativ platz sparend ist mir zugestreckt irgendwie gefällt mir nicht gut ist mir zugestreckt
in konsolata ja das kenne ich das habe ich unter windows schon was press start 2 das
ding heißt jetzt ernsthaft so oder press start font meine güte was nicht alles gibt
das probiere ich jetzt auch noch aus das hat so einen bescheuerten namen das ist bestimmt
pepega font was ist das was bin ich sehen da oben ah map ok es ist das mag ich mal leute
denn font von ihnen gibt es einfach nur ein style fris oder stirb gut ist wenigstens wenigstens
stehen in ihren design choices ja ok der ist cool der ist cool den würde ich nicht tagtäglich
benutzen aber der ist cool der ist cool das sieht aus als habe ich eine 320 mal 200 anwendung
auf fullscreen in konsolata in konsolata kenne ich das ist das ist die wind aus wobei
der ist cool der hat ganz ehrlich das ist der der der junixte font den wir heute hatten
ich glaube ich könnte nicht wirklich darin den ganzen tag programmieren wenn ich ehrlich
bin aber es ist auf jeden fall eine coole geschichte ok jetzt als letztes noch microsoft
font das bitmapigste ja obwohl es kein bitmap ist fack aller was zum ultra condensed medium
ich mache jetzt einfach inkon ok das ist ein bisschen ein bisschen stark ein bisschen
stark condensed vielleicht die fonts funktionieren glaube ich nur gescheit mit dem wind aus
font renderer ganz ehrlich ich lasse ihn jetzt hier drin das ist das das ist immer
lustig ich werde garantiert jeden stream jetzt nach meinem font gefragt wenn ich das drin
lasse jeden stream wenn ich das den editor zeige max was hast du da für den font max
kannst du mal deine settings zeigen was benutzt du denn für den font wie ist der name von
dem font den du hast ach seit wann hast du denn den font max ich weiß genau das wird
jedes mal wenn ich den editor zeige gibt es fünf fragen im chat das w sieht abgeschnitten
aus oh ich glaube das liegt daran dass ich irgendwas mit der größe gemacht habe ich
glaube ich habe die größe ich glaube ich habe mit der größe kaputt gemacht oder auch
nicht das gehört das gehört anscheinend so ich starte mal kurz neu das gehört anscheinend
so monac s ja nice der findet den finde ich cool ich meine ich würde im leben nicht
jeden tag täglich darin programmieren aber moment hat er hat er font lega ne hat er
nicht ne ich mag den font der finde ich cool mein man kann halt leider schlecht oh und
oh und so unterscheiden aber es geht halbwegs jetzt ist auf jeden fall nice der ist halt
ein bisschen ausschbreit ich mein guck mal also ein buchstaben ist ja der pippo fett
also auf jeden fall cool welcher meso font war das dotted zero lg irgendwas also immer
so leute ich muss ins bett morgen aber noch einen tag dann ist wochenende excellent danke
für die subs falls ich was übersehen habe sorry leute sieht aber nicht so aus als habe
ich was übersehen hoffentlich doch habe ich zock drei dankeschön prime sab man könnte
jetzt ja eigentlich in twitch in twitch nachgucken anstatt hier durch zu scrollen warum gucke
ich nicht in twitch nahe wohl snap storm megonne eine vor einer stunde schon dankeschön für
den sub huge subscriptions leute massive so puma max geht schlafen leute wir sehen uns
gar nicht du gehst einfach in dem menü in die datei und schreibst was rein das ist normal
dass die standardmäßig leer ist die ist immer standardmäßig leer da schreibst du nur sachen
rein die du überschreiben willst oder du machst über das ui wie ich eben es gibt settings
ui und settings jason die du anpassen kannst also leute wir sehen uns ich gehe jetzt ins
bett und dann sehen wir uns die tage bis denn zu macht's gut